As soon as we go.
Lot five seconds now.
Josh was just telling me about how he's
going to start his own cult.
Yeah,
for sure.
Absolutely.
You know,
uh,
everything else,
it seems like fucking work to me.
So yeah,
starting your own cult,
if you could pull it off.
The key is to not take it too far.
Don't get too crazy,
you know,
I dunno if I have that ability though,
man.
I'm sitting here wearing,
you know,
black metal tee shirts and you know,
listen to the crazy ass music.
I think taking it too far is,
it's kind of in my nature.
You still driving the muscle car?
Oh yeah.
Every day,
man.
All about muscle cars.
All Muscle car plus in this traffic
still drives a manual.
Yeah.
That's Gangsta six speed.
It sets your method number one method of
transportation.
If you're driving a man respect drive,
a manual transmission,
fucking Orange County.
You're still in Orange County?
No,
no,
no.
I've been out of Orange County for a
while.
I was in downtown for a while and then,
uh,
and I live in Hollywood,
like a vampire kind of also getting a
lot of extra sparring and Hobos and
knives and stuff like that.
Oh,
were you in like the bad area of
downtown is there?
Well,
you know what,
here's the thing about the bad area of
downtown.
It doesn't stay in the bad area of
You know it,
it's like,
oh well this is a really nice,
oh,
we got a quaint little lofts and loud
died.
It's like,
by the way,
you see that schizophrenia crack head,
he's going to fuck your shit up.
You know,
it's like Hancock Park,
you know where Hancock Park is?
Hancock quark is fucking amazing.
It's like one of the most beautiful
sexual urges.
But you can go two blocks down and you
got gang graffiti,
like,
like two blocks down.
You're in some sketchy area.
Like as soon as you get out and you
start going east further,
like you get some fucking sketchy
neighborhoods within a mile of these,
like 1920s mentions of old Hollywood
money mean those things are incredible.
Right.
And to me it's just like,
wow,
it's the most fantastic tourist guide
ever.
Like,
Hey,
come to la,
you might get fucked or you might not
sleep.
Roll the dice.
Let's see how this works out.
Yeah.
If you want to walk through downtown La,
you could,
you could take a wrong turn and a
walking dead episode.
You could be just strolling down
seventh,
everything's looking great.
You're passing uh oh seven grand and
Malo and all this stuff and then all of
a sudden,
Oh shit,
where the hell am I?
That guy's got a tent,
but I don't really think he's camping.
He people who think that their downtown
is fucked up,
you don't even know what fucked up is.
You need to see skid row like people
don't see,
I've shown people skid row and they go,
that's not real.
It looks fake as fuck.
It looks like an episode of the walking
dead.
And the first time I drove through it
and there was like some,
and I'm seeing all these just people
just,
just milling about and it must have been
later in the night,
like not super late but getting to
probably six or seven or it's because at
some point there there's this mission or
something down there and it's got this
gated courtyard and at some point they
close that gate and there was just
people inside the courtyard and there
were people outside of the courtyard
that was his like clamoring to get into
this thing and it was just insanity.
I go,
fuck man,
this is straight out of like some sort
of dawn of the dead.
If you get in by a certain amount of
time,
you're locking,
you can stay in there.
Yeah,
I guess whatever.
Shit.
So like some people like they've got to
get away from the crazy people on the
street,
I guess,
or probably get some place to sleep and
eat and what have you.
You know,
and you know,
it's tell each other psalms.
Isn't it weird that we look at people
like Dan will go,
yeah,
you're,
you're a loser.
Like all you people,
we're not going to help you change any
of the,
it's,
it's easy to do that because to look at
the situation on a,
on a far more complex level,
you know,
looking for what all the issues that can
write into this.
I mean a majority of these people are
probably mental health issues.
So there are crazy to simplify it and
then they get into these,
let's say drugs come into play or other
things.
I mean,
they just,
they need help,
right?
And there are some people there that
may,
maybe they are just total fucking down
and outers that they just gave up on
life in one way or another got hooked on
something or hooked on something else.
But I mean,
at the end of the day,
it's,
it's too easy.
It's much easier for people to just look
at it as like,
these guys are losers.
There's loses of the system and where
I'm some sort of a winner.
But I mean they,
in a way,
some of these people were born losers.
Then I guess because they didn't get to
choose to be born with schizophrenia or
any of these other sorts of things and
have childhoods.
There's a host of factors that plays in
to someone being like that,
but it's weird how we get to,
someone gets to a certain age,
like you're 35 you were homeless for a,
sorry dude.
Can't help you.
I feel like a 10 if you're 10 on the
street,
homeless will a call.
Come on buddy.
He's a little guy.
Scammed.
Yeah.
Who's just,
who's his parents left him and he didn't
have any food and he's got a really cute
newsboy cap.
It just seems so scrappy,
you know?
I think I'd like to make him my sidekick
and we're going to travel around the
world with him everywhere.
He's got a bag on the end of a stick.
Yeah.
Look at that bindle man.
He's been places.
That was the move that they had.
Here's this is re we're looking at video
right now and what's the name of this
video pulled up like skid row says
homeless on skid row in Los Angeles,
all in caps.
And it's fucking crazy.
It's a,
a whole series of homemade tents at
these people put together.
They've created these like little
apartments,
a little structures and they're on the
street and there's,
I mean this is a pretty good video of,
it just shows you how weird it is,
but it's way crazier at night.
Well it's even this just shows you were
just looking at one street.
Yeah.
And we're only looking at like a few
structure.
It's like a little square radius of
streets that encapsulate this,
this,
this area.
And you know,
I mean some people are like,
well,
oh yeah,
it's not really that dangerous.
And I'm like,
well,
I guess it really depends on the person.
I personally,
I wouldn't stroll around down there.
I feel like I'll be all right,
but why increase my likelihood,
you know,
having some sort of issue,
especially if somebody is literally
crazy,
it's,
it's really not a matter of whether
they're jerk or
whatever.
It's just they're operating in unstable,
irrational way.
So there's no way to,
uh,
to negotiate that very negotiated,
no way to even know if it's going to
happen.
Right.
And when someone's completely bonkers,
this some guy doing it on his bike
through it,
whoa,
that dude's got skills.
Let's get some bike skills.
[inaudible] on the front of his bike,
die death.
See each egg.
Oh,
the bunny pegs in the front.
So maybe he could have,
he could pick up a guy.
I grabbed one homeless dude.
He put them on the front and then they
can go like,
well,
the steering wheel.
That's,
is that an impressive,
that handlebar thing he just did?
That shit's incredible bark.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's not incredible.
I can't do it,
but,
but does that like a standard move,
Josh Barnett?
Uh,
you know,
I do know how to ride a bicycle.
Probably not to the level of this guy
doing that.
Flipping the bar around.
That's fucking,
that's pretty wild.
It's a,
it's like having a fidget spinner.
This is,
except if you fuck it up,
you're falling down.
You're just eating shit and losing
teeth.
Yeah.
I don't ride bikes much like that.
Bam.
That shit's incredible.
Camera edit too sure is.
Wow.
We,
oh,
that's pretty slick.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's an interesting dynamic and then
it's not a simple situation to solve
either.
Right.
You know,
it's like some people would would easily
just look at it like,
oh,
I'll just get rid of them.
It's like,
well,
you can't just do that with somebody.
I mean,
that's not the way you do it.
Is there a way to reprogram someone?
I think who,
I forget who the quote was by some
famous dude,
Frederick Douglass,
but he said it's a,
it's much easier to raise good children
and the repair broken men.
I can believe that.
Yeah.
You know,
we have,
it's,
it's always harder to take a fighter
with a bunch of bad habits and try to
cure them of that or reestablish new
good habits than it is to just start off
teaching them something correct from
the,
from the fucking get go.
Yeah.
You always see that for whatever reason
with kicking technique if kicking
technique,
like a lot of guys that come from bad
backgrounds,
they have a really hard time like maybe
karate to Moy,
Tai real hard time transitioning over.
And like I would see it even in
taekwondo guys that came from a karate
background didn't understand the
importance of raising the knee up above
the hip.
It's like when things got weird,
they couldn't pick their knee up for
certain kids and it,
it also did,
I guess it would depend a lot on that
style of cutoff day.
So like one of my guys show her Yamamoto
is a,
he's a junior world champion and kilkee
when he was the youngest ever to compete
in the world open weight tournament at
18 years old.
And,
uh,
and he was like 190 pounds when he did
it.
180 and 18 years old.
There's fighting holy shit.
You know,
like your glover test Sherra's and with
guys like that.
Yeah.
To kilkee shit is crazy too.
When you watch those guys punch full
blast the body but kick to the head like
not punching to the face.
I don't know where that really came
about necessarily,
but yeah.
Yeah.
You can kick them full on in the face.
Kneed him in the face.
Crazy things like that.
But don't,
don't throw a punch to the face,
but it's like his kicks are pretty
awesome.
The next level
of taekwondo,
it's like taekwondo.
They said you couldn't punch to the face
but you could kick above the waist and
calc.
Shannon's like,
how about we kick the legs too and elbow
and elbow.
And I'm like,
okay.
Yeah,
it's better.
It plus it doesn't get stopped as much
even though taekwondo is supposed to be
continuous.
Uh,
like Olympic style.
Yeah.
They clench or appoint get scored and
the raffle kind of,
well,
you know,
there's always these little breaks.
It seemed to happen,
you know?
Yeah.
It's,
it's interesting because I always feel
like for little kids,
especially what's really good about
taekwondo is a same thing that's really
good about gymnastics and even like
cheerleading control and flexibility and
yeah,
there's all kinds of readers,
right?
I think taekwondo can be really great
for that as well.
Yeah.
I think a lot of,
if you're going to do taekwondo or
really any,
a lot of these traditional martial arts,
it really depends on that teacher that
makes,
that makes it or breaks it.
I mean,
you could have like some old,
uh,
take you on like gnarly old Korean dude
who was going to teach you how to punch
to the face and throw people and all
kinds of stuff,
but maybe gear your competition training
towards the rule set that's allowable,
but,
or you could just have some dude that
just wants you to flip around and scream
at your points,
which is the most ridiculous almost up
there with like flopping and soccer,
like flopping and soccer's hit some new
levels lately.
People think they know that.
I think it's hilarious as some good sent
me one and the guy doesn't even get hit.
The other guy like throws his hand back
and it doesn't even come near him and
the guy launches himself through the
hair rising on the ground.
I've never seen anything like it.
What is it that,
how,
how does one graduate to that position?
You know,
here I'm,
I'm out here,
I'm playing a sport at let's say the
highest level and I'm competing against
other incredible athletes and we train
our asses off and we develop all these
skill sets and we get so good at
handling a ball with our feet.
And not even for foot fetish stuff,
but,
but just to play this game,
and I'm going to now concede in such,
like completely destroy all the
toughness,
all the grid,
all the work,
all the,
all the things that I've developed
mentally to,
to be able to run and kick and do all
this stuff and build up all these wind
sprints.
And then I'm just going to see a guy
swat his hand at me and then I'm a fling
myself on the ground and screamed bloody
murder.
They w they flap like fish.
I don't they flop around the ground and
twist and writhing in agony there has,
there's like a mental disconnect that
has to happen like you must just like
I'm going to bitch myself out right now.
I'm going to completely just destroyed
every element of toughness within me.
I think they're just willing to do
anything to get some sort of an
advantage and I don't know what,
I don't understand soccer.
I don't know the rules so I don't know
what kind of an advantage you would get
if you handle the shots penalty shot,
so you would get like pretty close to
the goal.
Yeah,
they get to,
they get to take a shot on goal or
something like that.
Pretty sweet.
It is.
That's just too much persuade.
I just couldn't do it.
I think it's worth too much.
I think what you got to do is if
somebody does you,
if somebody like actually fouls you,
that guy just gets removed and they
bring in a new player.
Like it seems pretty simple like this
panel,
they have reduced the uh,
the element there and in terms of what,
what the reward is,
the risk or an hour,
you see people flopping like penalize
them 100%.
Yeah.
That guys for a year.
You're slowing the game down and you're
making us look like shit.
So stop.
People are talking about you on podcast,
Bro.
That's not good.
You have no idea what happened to that
game without Mike.
They came.
I've been for the championship of the
world between the two greatest teams of
all time.
I don't know about that.
No,
I just know that dude flopping around
and we saw the Jamie flopped on this.
Preflop get the fuck out of here.
Did they call it flopping?
Are we making that up?
They call it flopping and soccer day.
She called it taking a dive.
Oh,
interesting.
Alright.
Oh,
oh no way.
Oh my God.
A little bit.
That is hilarious.
Are you kidding?
The Oh my God.
Watch this one.
That is hilarious.
I'm so hurt.
Oh God.
And the guy standing right there.
That's the thing.
You know the ref has to adjust,
which needed to grab.
Did he grab you grabbed his right.
Oh,
now,
now they flop out on his right.
Did he land on his right knee?
Okay.
That guy might have blown his knee out.
Hold on.
Go back to the ref because the ref might
have blown his knee out because I'm
looking at the way he falls.
Like washed.
Not this guy.
The next guy.
That guy here washes.
Oh no,
he's standing around.
Then he'd just,
he leaps onto the ground one more time.
Oh,
and he starts grabbing his shin.
No,
I think he's grabbing his knee now.
He might have his Shin Guard is fucking
bullshit.
I mean they have these guys just kind of
flops out of the huddle.
That's ridiculous.
It's almost as if these guys are so
tuned to any touch that once they feel
it,
they immediately just,
they die.
They fall down,
they cry.
If they're screaming
box,
that's where you get the penalty shot
and that can literally change the whole
game.
Oh,
oh.
So people just fall down when they just
fell on his own right next to him.
Oh,
so they just try to fall down and get
hurt.
Oh that's hilarious.
So was that the guy just stopped and the
other guy,
we used him as like a tripping mechanism
because if you can get the right card,
you can get a guy taken out of the game
and then you're at a huge advantage for
the rest of game.
Like if you could manipulate it ref and
the MMA fight,
which you kind of can I suppose,
but like you can't get the other guy's
Dick cute all the time.
There's definitely rules for that.
And here you just got to trick a guy.
Did you see that?
There's like a I understood of like,
yeah,
we're fucking with the game right now.
We're pretending to be hurt all the
time.
This is Larry is,
what is the name of this video?
It's like best flops or funny dives of
2017 funny dives and simulations just
this year.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
We'll see.
Some of them,
they're exaggerating.
This is not the best edit because some
of these guys are just getting tripped.
I mean,
they're just falling like that guy's
just falling like this is stupid.
Edit.
Yeah.
Is there also the best athletes of all
time?
Like the shit.
I be just falling.
Oh,
okay.
I see what you're saying there.
Yeah,
but people fall,
you know?
I mean the other ones,
there's so many of these that are like
that.
That shit is so ridiculous.
Look,
oh my God,
I can't make it.
I mean,
that shit is so funny.
It's like there's a culture of falling
and pretending you're hurt.
There's a little,
they could be,
I mean,
I don't know if they really are because
it probably takes away from their
stature as an athlete,
but getting in these videos where you're
just getting shown all over the Internet
again.
Honestly,
a couple of these were guys doing goofy
stuff and then laughing about it as like
ha,
I guess it's just what we do.
We pretend to be heard all the time.
And so it's some sort of an accepted
culture with,
oh my God,
I just falls down.
It's accepted within the culture of
playing the game.
As much as I can understand now that guy
taking a dive made sense cause he saw
the other detail and all that.
It's great.
These guys just touched faces and then
fell to the ground.
Like they get hit with meteors.
There's snipers out there just in the
audience just picking them off left and
right.
They just fall down like in agony.
Oh look at this guys.
Like look at this guy just falling down.
What do you do?
What you're doing that thing.
Stop doing that.
God,
it's a,
they have to revamp the rules.
Yeah.
Clip.
They've uh,
they started finding people that were
doing it,
but I think they sort of cut back on the
fines.
They tried to make it monetarily not a
good thing to do.
I know Ian Edwards love soccer and I
love Ian and he's trying to get me to do
a soccer companion,
but I feel like about soccer would I do
about like speaking Latin?
Like it's just some shit that's just
leftover from a long ass time ago.
It's currently code if we still remember
how to do it.
So he,
we don't,
we don't want to not know what Latin is
and like how,
what the word,
we don't want to get so confused that we
think this is like some forgotten
languages,
but uh,
especially since it's within all of our
scientific,
uh,
tax and all that.
But it's nonsense,
right?
Yeah.
That's nonsense.
I would rather than Latin then learn how
to flop out of fake injuries.
I just,
I don't know about that.
But you respect a,
an actual skillful soccer player.
Those guys are awesome athletes.
Actually.
What,
what,
what makes it so a disappointing is that
I know how good those dudes are.
I know that they must be super talented
and great,
very skillful and in great shape to then
take to get yourself to that level to
let's say,
elite level at your sport,
at your skillset.
Jimmy Aldo.
Who?
Josie.
Aldo.
Play soccer.
Oh,
I'm not surprised.
Amazing.
Yeah,
I bet.
Like professional level.
Do you think he would flop?
Nope.
I cannot see that happening.
I don't think so.
That's probably what held him back.
It's too busy throwing low kicks
at the,
instead of,
instead of kicking the ball,
he's just chopping people's legs out
from under him.
Yeah.
There's some video of him playing and
moving around and he's fucking really
good.
Which,
where's Aldo?
That ball?
That was him doing the ball flip.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Watch this.
Look at that.
We're really,
that's one of the best players in the
world.
He did it against Neymar.
Now do you think they're just playing
and having a good time as a charity
match?
Right.
Just sticking around but still look at
this.
I don't think he's just like,
okay guys,
like,
look,
ain't running for real,
dude.
I have actual games to play.
I'm not blowing out my acl,
like trying not to get pumped by an MMA
fighter.
Right,
exactly.
It's like,
okay,
you can have this moment,
but I've seen videos of him practicing
and playing.
He's like,
like a real professional soccer player
you're looking at and be like,
wow.
Yeah.
It didn't surprise me in the least I was
that Jose.
Yeah.
He,
he goes,
hey,
just he's kicking three pointers in
where he's trying at least,
hey,
uh,
I would never happen for me.
Never.
I played like little intermural soccer
and college for a second,
which just like these pickup games with
all the international kids.
I just thought it'd be a good way to get
in shape.
I didn't know really much about playing
soccer,
so he too big a,
I don't know if there's really a too big
around that much.
Well there's also that not good enough.
There's that,
that part too,
when these,
when these dudes from like Scotland and
Argentina and all over who would play
like all their like triple a leagues and
stuff and I mean I'm out there playing
defense and I could hustle.
I had quick feet and I wasn't movable so
that was kinda good.
But uh,
you know,
at one point,
uh,
they see my team kept trying to get it.
I get an opportunity for me to score on
goal and I'm like,
no,
quit.
You know,
I got good enough to dribble and pass it
away a little bit.
Don't fucking ask me to kick this thing
is never going to go where I want it to
and it's just careening off everywhere.
It plus this dude from Argentina was
just all over me every single time.
I'm like,
everyone else is like,
oh,
it'd be funny if he could be great if he
could get a shot and this guy like fuck
fat,
I'm going to fucking,
I'm on.
I'm like stink on shit.
Am I wrong?
Taking it,
there's like a build that would excel at
football,
which you think so?
I could think so.
And then I would think that soccer would
require,
because you run so much.
I would think tall and lanky would be
good for soccer or even maybe just a
long leg.
Short torso.
Yeah.
But that messy guys are like really
small.
Right.
That's just like super fast.
Just being very quick.
Yeah.
It's been very quick and very agile and
being able,
but I was just thinking tall cause then
you could more headers,
more body up,
up top.
Let me ask you this.
As a proponent of violence,
why?
How come rugby never took off here?
That seems to me to be the real sport.
Ah.
You know,
I don't really know why.
I think because American football is
American football.
Maybe.
Maybe that's why
seems kind of stupid in a way.
Because you have a helmet on pads and
you're running into each other and we
already know that that's not a good
idea.
It isn't.
It actually makes it way worse.
Right.
You can let harder.
They've figured out some new technology,
which I know they're working on some
packed resist in helmets and things that
which that kind of changes everything.
If they do that and they get it to the
point where guys can collide heads and
actually be okay.
I don't know.
I don't really think that I just there
they can get these,
these helmets that are going to take the
impact,
uh,
and reduce it and all that.
But I just,
once you're a 300 pound dude running a
four,
seven smashing into,
uh,
another 300 pound,
dude,
I just don't,
you know,
it's just like I would get in the
arguments with the,
uh,
with like these kids that,
at the University of Montana rugby team,
like,
he should come and play rugby.
You should play rugby.
I'm like,
no,
I want to fight.
And you know,
rugby that seems fun and all that,
but,
and well,
it's,
did you play football?
Yeah,
I played football all these way tougher.
I go,
AH,
hold on.
Uh,
you,
the pool you're drawing from,
I'm sure there's some good athletes.
The pool we were drawing from when I'm
going to University of Washington
football camp and when I'm playing
against,
you know,
nationally ranked teams like,
Oh,
day you,
this is different.
Yeah.
We're,
who they're drawn from is a much,
much bigger pool.
The stakes for them are much,
much bigger than you and your college
team floating around and then drinking
beers after your games.
This is not like that.
This is a different story.
You especially someone that has a
potential nfl career and they'll like
super focused.
You know,
if you look at the some of the super
athletes that you get that entered the
nfl to that just the sheer size and
speed that these guys have and it's only
so much that can be genetics.
You've got like some serious training
involvement and dedication.
Like they know how much money's
involved.
Exactly.
And there are people that are grooming
these athletes from a super young age to
to meet these requirements and so I was
like,
look,
rugby is super awesome.
It's tough.
It's a great sport.
I like Rugby League way better than
rugby union cause unions got all the
scrumming and all that.
It slows it down.
It's League is seven tackles.
I believe.
That's all you get.
You got to tell you get,
but you,
you,
it's constant.
You're constantly moving up the field.
What if you go more than seven?
Like what did you don't?
Once you hit seven,
you have to drop the ball and then they
change is over.
But it moves super fast and it's very
aggressive and it's just,
you know,
con it's like watching people play
wishbone the whole time.
They just constantly taking each other
down.
Yeah.
And so,
you know,
they're hitting,
boom,
this tackle happens.
Then they're going to try and shuttle
the ball back to their other teammate
and then shovel shoved the ball down the
line again and keep it moving until they
can finally break through watching the
other one.
To me it slows down way too much.
So I don't really enjoy it.
Which,
you know,
that's Kinda how the argument with
American football is that it slows down.
And to me,
I'm like American football,
I was like watching two armies go at it.
You set,
you have your,
your,
your skirmish,
you regroup,
you skirmish again,
you skirmish again.
And by the end of the,
all these skirmishes,
the war is either is won or lost by this
team.
Yeah.
That's the way I look at it.
But,
uh,
well,
you know,
that was,
it was designed to sort of placate
people.
What,
that's all games are designed to be a
diminishing aspect of war.
But American football in particular was
actually literally like systematically
designed,
like we know the time that it happened.
There's a whole radio lab podcast.
Okay.
It's pretty fascinating,
man.
And about how they ran into problems
when they let American Indians play with
white kids.
Oh yeah.
The natives are just fucking all the
white kids up.
That's a brutal last games and natives
did some gnarly shit.
Did they eat their hearts?
That kind of part of the problem.
I don't know what the problem was,
but uh,
it was an issue.
That was it.
Again,
it was an issue.
I would,
I would have loved,
you know,
Steve Rinella on recently and he was
talking about the guys who killed custer
and little big horn and one of these
guys were just this massive guy.
What does the name mall is that they
called them gall gall and he went on to
a wild wheels.
He was the Conan book.
Right.
Is there,
that'd be how cold a conquer.
Yeah.
Take it out.
Right.
But this guy was apparently just massive
and I mean,
I would've loved to have seen that with
my own eyes.
Like would it looks like to be like a
direct lineage of warrior culture?
Like if that guy was living in the 18
hundreds,
like he is directly from the original
native Americans that came here from
Siberia,
you know,
whatever.
Thousands and thousands of years ago,
that would be something,
fuck yeah.
Uh,
chief Seattle,
which my fucking phone don't work.
Fuck it.
Uh,
he had some quote about being at a
football game at the University of
Washington.
He was,
and I can't for the life of me remember
exactly how it goes,
but it was just like,
oh,
it's not a lot of white men fight each
other today.
I don't know why the hell you guys are
into this,
but whatever.
Yeah,
they didn't really have like,
like that kind of a game.
There's something uniquely brutal about
American football.
There is.
Oh,
and I look at rugby,
I'm like,
okay,
that to me seems more realistic.
It is more realistic.
I think in some ways,
um,
I,
it's,
it's even,
it's more brutal in some and less than
others.
Like I came in May versus maybe
kickboxing.
Yeah.
Well,
and the thing is at one of my arguments
with the rugby kids is like,
dude,
you,
you don't get hit as hard as you do in
American football as you're doing here
in rugby.
You just,
you're,
you're not,
um,
plus the athletes are smaller and you
know,
go do a kickoff.
Guys,
they talk about fucking insane.
But what would you think would happen if
like what if by some crazy reason people
decided,
hey look,
we're going to no longer do American
football.
We're going to do rugby,
rugby league,
which is open to regulate.
I don't totally understand the
difference between the two of them.
I'd have to watch a few games I guess.
But those guys who dominate and
football,
wouldn't you think they would be the
guys who dominate in rugby?
Yeah,
I do.
Everybody would just get bigger and
faster and stronger.
Yup.
We'd be just like American level
football players pretty much because
the,
if,
if we're talking that everybody would
switch over to rugby,
that means all these rugby teams in the
league and all that would then be the
ones with all the big deals in the TV
deals and all the,
all the money would funnel into it and
therefore the potential prosperity of it
would drive the interest for people to
try and apply there.
Where's it being not only a part of that
hero myth that would come with being a
champion football team player,
you know,
our rugby team player,
but also with the hero myth of just
being a part of that within,
you know,
your normal society or of this elite
exemption,
exceptional status,
this thing that stands alone that it
seems a bit foreign to your normal
person,
but also the money and the success that
comes from that kind of notoriety and
the doors that it opens in terms of,
um,
you know,
to use a overused word,
the privilege of being at that level,
at,
within that inner circle of exceptional
or seen as exceptional people.
Anyways.
Do you think?
What's the short drive?
It you've had a long career in mma,
long successful career,
but it's very rare.
It's very rare for someone to be
operating the same level that you're at
seven years is the cutoff.
Like once you get to about seven,
everything starts to just rapidly
decline.
Like he'd just fall to shit.
Do you think it's an injury thing?
Is it a training thing?
Is it just a life thing?
They didn't,
they didn't,
uh,
or at least they weren't able to single
out any particular factor in,
in general.
But you know,
there was a lot of theories as to why
that might be,
but they were able to track professional
fighters,
careers,
uh,
over length of time.
I think they had some metro having,
I don't remember,
but it's on the,
it's on the Internet.
Uh,
it,
uh,
I do believe that they have counted,
they were able to account for a number
of fights too and weigh that against
that metric and see how that may
influence things.
But seven years was this magic number,
like six,
seven years.
And once you start going over seven
years,
your,
your percentage of success started just
crumbling.
Like it was dramatic about how a guy
would be like 13 and three and he'd get
to seven years and all of a sudden it's
like 13,
six,
13,
seven,
13.
He just starts losing just about
everything.
Yeah.
Bj Penn's good example of that.
Right.
You know,
like there's certain,
there's a certain drop off where the
person just looks totally different and,
and you know,
we could honestly look,
it would be,
we would have to isolate a lot of
different factors to figure out any one
particular thing.
But there's so many elements that go
into being a professional fighter and
being successful at that.
And so for let's say we'll take Bj,
you know,
maybe,
maybe it is physicality,
maybe he's lost a little bit of a step.
His reactions are a little slower,
uh,
through any number of reasons why maybe
his,
his strength has diminished maybe
slightly or it's flexibility,
maybe certain physical elements
regardless of injury or not have
diminished enough that at where they
used to be.
It was an edge where it is now is evened
out or is or is below what is necessary
for him and how he fights to be
successful.
Uh,
maybe could be beyond physical
deterioration.
Maybe it's just mental,
uh,
elevation.
Yeah,
exactly.
So maybe he's just not as motivated to
push in the same ways that he was or
maybe he's not able to,
uh,
I don't know,
recognize,
uh,
things that he was five years ago,
six years ago,
and seeing those opportunities and being
able to react on them quicker.
Uh,
there's a number of things and
especially when it comes to mental now,
now you're getting into such a
subjective area that,
you know,
go,
pull that apart.
Yeah,
that's a really good point.
The mental aspect is a really good point
because who knows,
you know,
the only,
only the person that's competing knows,
we really never have any idea how,
what's going on inside a person's head.
I mean,
for me,
I decided to take a break after my
Arlovski fight and that was somewhat
physically based,
but most of it was mental.
I,
uh,
I just didn't,
I had no interest to go into any kind of
training camp to put myself through all
that again to then to fight again.
You know,
it's just for one when you start off
fighting and what those goals are too,
as you get further in and further in and
further in and,
you know,
getting it 20 years of being a
professional fighter and being a top 10
heavyweight and arguably and top five
most of the time for Shit,
16 of them,
something like that and high level
competition and uh,
it's just,
and youngest ever UFC heavyweight
champion.
That's right.
That was until that,
that son of a bitch,
Jon Jones came and beat me out by a few
months.
That talented bastard.
Now you're the youngest ever.
Yeah,
just heavyweight champion instead of the
youngest ever UFC champion.
But,
um,
it's,
it got to a point where it's just like,
well,
you know,
my reasons for fighting are essentially
still the same,
but all,
I don't have the same motivation to go
out there and be like,
oh,
I'm going to conquer the whole world.
I'm fight.
I can beat that guy.
Could be,
I know I could beat guys.
Like it doesn't,
I don't,
I'm not trying to prove it to myself
anymore,
you know,
but that fire that wants to fight still
exist.
Just like,
well,
you know what,
I'm going to take some time to work on
some of the other stuff that is going to
be more of my life after this because
fighting is going to end sooner than
this stuff is.
How old are you now?
39.
Now when you think about,
do you have like a number in your head?
Like when I hit 42 or,
no,
no.
I don't,
I don't have anything set like that.
I just figured that if I'm being honest
with myself and self aware,
the,
I'll know when that time has come,
when that,
that moment is,
is getting to that,
that edge where if you keep going,
it's gonna fucking it's going to go
downhill versus okay,
you've got right to that point.
Call it fucking good.
Move on.
And there's still athletic windows open
to me with grappling and maybe a few
other in professional wrestling.
Uh,
but,
uh,
fighting is going to be a much shorter
window and the fact that I've got 20
years out of it or however long that I
take this to is going to be pretty
phenomenal.
Yeah,
it's pretty incredible.
Are you thinking about doing some more
grappling?
Yeah.
I mean I've been approached by a few
things but uh,
either dollar wise just to really hasn't
made sense or mainly that's just it and
uh,
I feel like it's just one thing that
people have to figure out as super
popular and get it until,
or super exciting rather than give it on
television.
So many watches like your match with
Dean lister,
you know,
you're the first guy to tap out dean
lister and how many years?
Like 17 years or 15 years.
Something crazy.
And you caught them a scarf hold.
Oh yeah,
it had an arm boom.
Judo style.
Yeah,
it's fucking bad ass.
Here's the thing,
I had seen that the last time you'd been
subbed.
Was that really?
Yeah.
So I already knew that and I'm like,
well,
I'm going to put this in my back pocket
if I need it later on in the match.
And after I've been riding him and
grinding on him and beating on him.
Once he's huffing and puffing,
I can get it.
I know it's going to be real hard for
him to stop this.
And so sure enough,
I look up and it's like,
oh shit,
I don't have a lot of time left.
Boom,
hit it.
Go.
And it worked.
Yeah.
And then he run,
gracie was a big feather in your cap to
because he,
ron is what,
one of the most respected young
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt guys out
there.
Like he's super respected.
His and defensively like re very tough
defensively,
didn't,
couldn't tap him.
Uh,
he all those guys like here on Hallock,
uh,
Henner they were all very successful
when they were competitors and I know
people want it.
Yeah,
they were,
they were kicking butt a fact.
What was it?
Henner tapped Jeff Munson back in the
day.
I think it was a quick triangle.
So,
uh,
when here on was the only guy that how
it could get to step up and wrestle me.
That was,
that was the option.
There was all these heavyweights and all
these dudes and I'm like,
I found a bunch of guys that had,
I had recently competed and won belts
and stuff or one tournament like,
Hey,
pick,
what about that guy?
Now he's like,
he won't do it back.
I won't do it.
That guy won't do it the whole bunch
from,
I'd be like,
well they won't do it without the G.
And I'm like,
okay,
well that's,
you know,
that's not an option.
So why even bring it up?
See that black dude,
really high level Brazilian Jujitsu
world champion guy who wanted to get in
there with you.
There have been,
but well no.
Well there are a few like cyborg wanted
to do it,
you know,
but then that's an interesting one guy.
He got interested,
he got injured and so then it was like,
well how do we fill that gap?
What kind of injury do you have?
Do you know?
Rib,
I think.
I didn't really look into it too much
for me.
It was just a matter of that matches and
happening.
Right.
Move on,
you know,
try to salvage this thing.
And so I like to see that match though
in the future.
That would,
I think there'll be really interesting.
I could happen.
It could happen.
I trained for it.
I felt real confident going into it.
I really wanted it to,
because everybody was like,
as soon as I beat Dean,
well the first thing was,
oh,
what an idiot.
He's wearing shoes.
Oh,
that's a dumb is saying he's going to
get his leg tore off.
What?
How he's so dumb.
And then I went,
it's like,
what a cheater.
He wore his shoes,
gave him such an advantage.
He had so much grip.
Oh,
that's bullshit.
It's like,
which is it?
Oh,
he was to 70 and dean was 185 pounds.
Like,
what are you talking about?
I was like two 50 and dean was like two
30 the guy was a big massive,
and people forget he,
he's pretty thick dude.
I remember giving him a hug at the quote
unquote way.
I mean,
we didn't weigh in and I'm like,
Ooh,
this dude is silverbacks status right
now.
He's huge.
Yeah.
He's a fucking massive guy.
He's strong and talented too.
And so I'm like extremely technical,
very.
And you know to,
to me,
I'm seeing all the blue belts going nuts
out there and I'm like,
well,
he's a,
he was a heavyweight too,
so I didn't just go out there and
outsize him.
You know,
I used my game on him and yeah,
I wrote him heavy.
You know,
butch is a skill to develop,
but um,
you know,
you don't see dean making excuses.
I mean we just went out there and gave
it our best and I was able to beat him
that day.
Well deems one of the best leg lockers
in the country.
Yeah,
I mean really it's like super
knowledgeable and when it comes to any
aspect of Jujitsu,
but in particular leg locks.
And he spent a bunch of Tom on the east
coast at Henzel his place.
And Eddie Bravo said that's sort of
where hens,
those place became like this leg lock
Mecca.
You think of like Gary,
Tony,
planet teens and John Donahoe like,
yeah,
his,
his like what teachings that he lent in
over there sort of spread.
And now they've,
since Donna her was a real wizard since
spread it into his own sort of ideas and
philosophies on a task.
That's the thing.
You just never know what can come of,
of any,
even the smallest to largest influence
allowing that that seed can take place
anywhere,
but someone may tend to that garden and
all of a sudden boom,
you know,
a big export,
a big expansion from that idea can come
from it.
And that's,
you know,
one of the great things it was,
that's one of the things that people
like about you is that you're,
you,
most of the time you're going old
school.
I mean,
you're doing catch wrestling stuff.
you're doing like the shit that Karl
gotch and all those dudes from those uh,
old school wrestling catch wrestling
books.
Like a lot of those submissions,
you're proven those things to be 100%
legit.
Yes.
And I,
you know,
I understood,
I understand completely the,
some of the incredulousness about
looking at that and being like,
that doesn't fucking work because you
think,
well,
if it did it would be everywhere.
But for one it's just there's just not
enough people teaching it.
So that's really diminishes the ability
to expand it.
Although like myself and,
uh,
all the people from the Japanese shoot
wrestling side that that has come from
like Sakharova and my Fujiwara.
I mean there's nothing that people,
we explained that connection cause it's
really kind of fascinating that who
will,
who went over there was it,
it's called [inaudible] Antonio Gnocchi
to create the new Japan pro wrestling
Dojo and teach all of his student all,
all of the wrestlers,
how to be catch wrestlers and to give
them a foundation and basically
shooting,
which is real fighting.
So then they could go out there and work
these matches,
but keep the intensity,
the realism,
uh,
the,
it's like the difference between,
and I know you're not the biggest fan of
professional wrestling.
How dare,
how dare you,
I dare,
I dare if I had a gauntlet,
I would throw it.
I'm sure there's a gauntlet in here
somewhere.
Look at this fucking place.
Yeah.
Uh,
but,
uh,
you know,
I also understand some of the gripe with
looking at like where the way wrestling
has been for quite a while now.
It's like,
oh,
so it got outed,
right?
So everybody knows it's worked.
So people operate on this premise that
it's fake.
So whatever,
like why bother?
Make it real anymore.
Let's just fake it up all the way.
And then people would open up skills and
it would be like if,
if,
uh,
if all magicians were just like,
hey,
look,
all of our tricks,
they're not real.
They're not real magic.
Here's how you do them all.
And then I'm going to open up schools
and just teach everyone,
you know,
just pay me 500 bucks for three months.
And now you too can be a magician.
And it's just like,
well,
uh Oh man,
that would ruin going to magic shows.
It would just make it so shitty.
But you know,
that's how a lot of these,
these guys get into wrestling now.
That would never be restless.
Like to be a wrestler back even in say
the 70s,
early eighties,
you had to be a fucking tough guy.
Like dusty roads.
You look at him and you're like,
that guy is not tough.
You're like,
no,
actually he was recruited by the fucking
Miami Dolphins and he was like,
ah,
I think I can make more money being
arrested then I can be in a football
player back then.
You know,
or ric flair was like a all American or
college,
Big Time College football player.
And he went and trained under a vern
Ganja and uh,
Billy Robinson at the,
at this barn out in Minnesota somewhere.
And they would have to run miles and
lift weights and do squats and wrestle
each other for real.
And it's just like all these dudes,
you think it's like,
oh yeah,
Woo.
And all that.
These motherfuckers had to go through
some real shit and they had to prove
themselves to be legitimately tough
enough to be even a professional
wrestler to work matches and they used
to hold do things like hold tryouts and
people would come down,
they paying their money.
Then these wrestlers would just run them
into the ground and then all right,
whoever's left,
whoever could get through the endurance
part of this,
okay now you're going to get in the ring
with some dude and then they would just
get the shit tortured out of them.
The APP,
you know,
just totally ripped apart and then like,
all right,
cool bye.
He didn't make it because that's just
the way it was.
You couldn't become worked right cause
it used to be,
it was one point in time.
It was like they would do like pro
matches in 30 intervals,
maybe their thirties like a farmer
Burns' date.
Right,
exactly.
So originally professional wrestling
catch catch as catch can was 100% real
like these guys,
this is how people would travel the
world.
This is how midsole my Ada that you Doka
Jiujitsu guy ended up in Brazil
doing catch wrestling pro wrestling
matches and then ended up staying in
teaching judo and Jujitsu and catch
wrestling through the gracies,
the,
the actual birth of Brazilian Jujitsu,
which is amazing because you could trace
it.
Yes.
It started as catch,
catch the started judo and catch
wrestling and can we pull up because of
it burns hanging himself.
Oh yeah.
The hang mantric.
Yeah.
He used to,
his neck was so strong that he would do
this trick where he would put a noose
around his neck and drop and hang from
his men and support his,
and he was probably about 170 pounds.
I'm like,
oh,
something like that.
Yeah.
And it would hang from his neck and not
die.
Yes.
Which most of us.
How do you even get to that point?
How do you test that theory?
Do you like ease into it?
To think that just an off ever while I
was doing it.
I hope so.
What a wasted opportunity.
Maybe David Carradine.
Chill guys to fucking hang himself.
Go.
Go to the one where you see his full
body,
the far left there.
Yeah,
look at that.
I mean the guy had a neck that was so
fucking strong.
He literally could hang himself.
I mean he had his hands free so it could
reach up and grab the rope I guess.
But uh,
I mean I wonder how long you would
survive doing that.
I Dunno.
I could make it hard to,
uh,
to give him a blowjob afterwards.
Yeah,
for sure.
There's certain dudes that like,
you look at them today and you don't
think of them as being like 20 inch neck
on 165 pounds.
It's amazing.
I mean,
any whistles?
Yankee doodle.
Oh Jesus Christ muscles.
While we can be dropped from six feet,
what,
what?
Drop from six feet.
So it probably wasn't even six feet
tall.
So he's dropping it from his own height
and catching with his fucking neck and
then he whistles.
Yeah.
Is a gay for pay pro body builders as
well as maybe mel prostitute.
Hey,
gay for pay.
what are those little things that they
put on CNN?
Stuff like that,
like miracle weight loss cure,
and then you go pay dad.
Like what does,
what do you have these paid ads?
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
I leave what she looks like today.
And you're like,
what the fuck is this?
So you're running that through a CNN
through like an accredited news website.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
This is the kind of stuff that people
did in the late 1900 for fun because
there wasn't anything like TV.
No Internet.
So what do you do?
You end up hanging yourself from seeing
if he could drop from six feet.
I wonder how many people tried to
emulate that and it just didn't work
out.
Talk about Darwinism.
Oh,
there had to be a lot,
right?
Yeah,
for sure.
Is there's gotta be some dummies like,
argh.
Fuck up.
Snap.
Yeah.
Oh,
for sure.
Oh Man.
There was a lot that died because there
wasn't a whole lot of entertainment back
then.
It was either that or get dysentery.
There's a crazy story going around.
Some youtube couple did,
some stunt where the other girl shot the
guy,
right?
Yeah.
And killed him.
Oh,
pt.
It was thick enough to stop a bullet
style.
And what kind of a round was it?
Cause uh,
a nine millimeter.
Even a low,
not,
not like a,
not a hot load.
One
hot mode.
Uh,
not even a real,
like a site,
like a personal defense round or
whatever it will pierce phone books.
No,
no problem.
Yeah.
I don't know what the fuck they were
thinking.
Can you imagine just having trust and
encyclopedias?
Well,
up a bullet.
They even test that out.
They put an encyclopedia on the ground
and shoot at first at this crazy bitch
probably.
She probably put some Kevlar and a book
and said,
look of even in the littlest buck will
stop a bullet.
And then she gave him the book with no
Kev warm plan.
Well,
I don't really believe that folks.
This is just a joke.
Don't sue me.
Women,
women and men,
man,
they can,
they figure out how to ways to be tricky
all the time or stupid.
It's fuck.
They figured you're dumb as fuck.
There's a lot of dumb as fuck out there.
It's just a matter of whether or not you
can survive it.
Dude,
I've been trolling the past a day on
instagram putting up these barriers.
Thoughts about bears?
Yeah.
So many people think I'm serious,
dude.
I wrote about forest rangers
infiltrating bear.
I saw it.
I read that.
And he'll try to find there too.
People are so fucking stupid.
It's like what we were talking about
before the podcast started about apple,
the forum cults and Right Tology Oh,
Ron Hubbard and all that shit.
Oh,
it's this the diminishing element of
have of critical thinking.
It's not just about the reduction of
critical thinking in today's society.
It is the effort that it takes to be a
critical thinker.
And four,
I would classify it under this,
under the,
this,
this concept I have that I've been
working with called the human entropy.
So entropy is the,
the in physics,
it's um,
things returning,
simply put,
it's things going to their load,
a state of energy and human beings,
human entropy will go to their lowest
date of energy,
given an opportunity.
And to the point where you see wally,
if you've seen that movie and all that,
the big fat out,
just gnarly people just floating around
on hover beds being fed and taken care
of and having zero strife in their life
that we will do that if given the
opportunity.
And so not having to think critically,
finding a group identity of some sort,
even as crazy as a cult or which I would
argue that there's a lot of ideologies
around nowadays that are just as
cult-like is as scientology or you know,
heaven's gates,
stuff like that helps a lot of people so
out of line,
uh,
but,
um,
to,
to be,
to belong in one of these groups,
to be a part of that identity means that
you no longer have to take as much
responsibility for your own actions
because this group has decided your,
your value system,
how you're going to operate your ethics.
It also,
I mean there's,
um,
some philosophical arguments that part
of that also ultimately stems from,
I think it was from Ernest Becker.
It stems from fear of death and having
to mitigate the anxiety and nihilism
that could come with confronting and
accepting the fact that you're going to
die and everything that you did is going
to die with you,
essentially.
Like your,
your lack of existence is coming around
the corner.
Not If you put on the purple Nike's and
cut your balls off.
Wait for the comment.
That's right.
You drink the Koolaid.
Did you hear how the,
the guy,
uh,
he saw everybody dying horribly and he's
like,
Jonestown,
yeah,
we'll fuck.
I'm not going to drink that.
Please.
You know,
do something else.
Instead it's like,
shoot me,
I don't want to,
I don't want to take the drink.
I'm sure it didn't they kill like 900
people or something like that.
Yeah.
Town something saying all of those
lines.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's very interesting watching people
just given to the influence of the hive.
Of course,
whatever hive that is,
whether it's a religious hive or I'm
fast and operates on the same
principles,
you know,
whether it be religion and you can tell
people,
of course,
to me religion is kind of one of the
ultimate ones because the,
everything we do has,
is,
is measured against a wager.
You know,
if we talk from,
from games.
So what,
what's at stake and cruises,
the importance or the of,
of the game itself.
So,
you know,
fighting increases that,
that threshold and so much higher
because the more greater potential for
death or hurt pain,
whatever,
right?
You're fighting somebody and as you go
down the lines,
but you know,
poker is,
is popular because the raised stakes,
the money as at play and the reward that
could come with it and the potential
that you could lose from it.
So everything has this,
this and value.
There's this measure against what
you're,
what you're potentially giving up.
And what's it,
what's it hazard.
So with religion,
what's it hazard,
your eternal soul,
something that is so high value that you
can't,
oh fuck,
I can't risk that.
So fuck,
I guess I better,
you know,
I mean it's,
that's why it's so powerful,
but also it is,
it is a panacea for death because like
Nicha we'll talk about the concept of
true world values.
This is not the true world.
This other thing is the true world.
So all of this suffering and strife and
difficulty and any like bullshit that
happens to me,
all of this,
in the end,
it really isn't gonna matter because
eventually I'm going to go to this true
world and this is the real world.
And this is the,
my payoff for all of the,
all the Shit I had to go through down
here.
And so for a lot of people,
the concept of having meaning for their
difficulty,
for their struggle is absolutely
important because otherwise,
why am I doing this?
You know,
to take your own existence,
your own being in the world and take it
on to yourself and have all your own
accountability and look at it as I'm
here living the best life I can because
I need to live the best life I can
because it's the only life I will ever
live.
Yeah.
That is a lot of weight.
And you know,
um,
the anxiety of people dealing with that,
trying to really take that on face on
with death and their,
their,
their lack of permanence in this world.
Uh,
that's the,
the argument is that was where nihilism
can come from.
And then with nihilism,
it's like,
well,
nothing matters.
So if nothing matters and you're not,
you're not able to,
to operate anymore,
you're just like,
what's the point?
The moment matters though.
Of course,
it does all of it.
Everything matters.
Well,
it see,
it's up to,
you do assign your values as to what
you're doing anyways and why you're
doing it.
Um,
but again,
that involves taking responsibility for
those values and caring those,
that burden of what that may be on your
own shoulders and not somebody who was
one of the reasons why learning some
kind of a discipline at an early age.
It's probably like really important for
people.
I think.
So.
I mean,
I think for me a lot of it came from
being ostracized as a kid and being
someone that was not of hive mentality
and out of herd mentality and that you
get ostracized.
For what?
Because of what?
Just,
uh,
for,
for one it was being bigger and for all
the things that I was interested in,
all the dorky stuff or weird stuff or
played dungeons and dragons,
I would,
if I had the time I play dungeons and
dragons,
I would play warhammer 40 k I would,
I still play magic the gathering from
time to time.
Oh yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Are you kidding me?
I tap that man a motherfucker.
Ooh,
I love it.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
you know,
for being into that kind of stuff,
but also just for being,
just for,
just being different.
And some of it was like big brother
syndrome stuff.
So it's like,
oh well you fuck with big brother
because it's fun.
And eventually he gets mad and he finds
you and he beat you up and you cry and
you know,
but you do it again the next day.
Anyways.
So for me it's like,
oh,
here's this big kid and he's going to
get upset if you start fucking with
them.
Uh,
and it's funny,
Haha until I get ahold of you.
And then it's like,
oh,
you just beat me up.
That's fucked up.
And I said,
well I didn't,
I didn't want to beat anybody up until
you started fucking ridiculing me in the
first place.
So,
but when you're a little child,
you don't understand regulation of
emotions as well.
You also don't understand the social
parameters in which all this stuff is
functioning anyways.
You just don't have that kind of
insight.
And so,
you know,
it'd be like nowadays someone could walk
in here and be like,
fuck you,
you suck.
And I look at him and I would laugh
about it because we were talking about
this yesterday.
I was saying that I saw it happen.
Chocolate,
Dell.
I have saw people try to pick fights
with chocolate dell and it's hilarious.
It's like,
yeah,
why are you fucking suicidal?
No,
no,
I have not.
I've never had anyone really try to pick
a fight with me.
I had a guy at a,
at a concert once,
I get all,
get all butthurt about me not letting
him pass in between me and this,
this girl that was standing with me,
cause people kept trying to cut through
to get it was at anthrax and he wanted
to get,
and I'm just like,
fuck this.
Why do people keep trying to walk
between us?
Like Jesus just go around,
right?
So eventually I'm like,
no,
I'm not letting anybody by.
So I got my elbows out and people would
bump into it and then go,
go around.
Well this guy,
he just kept going,
kept tap in.
It's just like,
man,
fuck you dude.
I'm standing here with a girl.
Go Away.
He was trying to give a treat and you
and your girl.
And so eventually you can get like a
Dick Rub.
Like,
uh,
maybe,
I mean,
if he'd asked nicely,
maybe he would've got one.
Well,
I don't know,
that's a bold ask.
But you know what though?
Fortune favors the bold and I'm a kind
human being.
Maybe he didn't want me to rub his dick,
but that's what he have got.
You would've got that to give and you
take sir.
So,
uh,
the guy comes around and he finally goes
around us and then he's just,
he looks at me,
he's like,
hey man,
I was trying to get through.
And I go,
look,
I'm standing here with this girl.
Like,
yeah,
go somewhat.
You just go around and he's getting all,
he's getting pissed about it cause I'm
dismissing him,
you know?
So eventually I was like,
just,
you know,
let's go,
let's walk away now that gets his
fucking hackles up and he's all mad and
he's,
he's looking at me,
he's like,
you,
this and that.
And I started laughing at him.
I go like,
Oh,
you want to,
you want to scrap because you can't get
through here.
Is that,
is that it is,
this is what you want to do.
And he's just like,
Wah,
Wah.
And I go,
okay,
we'll just move on.
Oh,
fucking chest up even bigger.
And it's just like,
he looks like he's going to walk away,
whatever I'm saying,
all right,
you know?
Okay,
do your own thing.
He's like,
Ooh,
he's just getting even more looked up.
And he points his finger out and I'm
laughing at him.
And the girl who,
uh,
who was,
does Jujitsu and was a fighter,
she reaches out and grabs the whole
disguise risks and pulls his hand out.
And she's like,
don't you don't want to do that?
And then he looks at her and he looks at
me and I'm just smiling and he pulls his
hand back and I go,
I know what must have gone through his
head is just like,
this girl's grip is serious.
And she's telling me,
don't fucking do it.
It's probably a good idea not to fucking
do it,
probably.
Exactly what,
but other times there have been like,
uh,
you know,
I'm not impervious to getting in a mood.
And so sometimes I've been out and about
and someone was being a dickhead.
And I see it and it's like,
okay,
this guy is,
he's,
he's clearly trying to egg something on
somehow.
And so maybe I,
you know,
add a little something to that scene to
feel if he'll,
uh,
he'll bite and just happen,
you know,
or I've had some people go,
oh yeah,
of course.
No one's going to fight you then know
who you are.
I'm like,
are you fucking kidding me?
I'm some sort of deal celebrity.
Nobody knows who the fuck I am.
So get away with a lot.
And the thing is,
if a guy who had a fight,
who would know who you are,
if a was a fan of fighting,
he would know who you are.
And those guys would be way less likely
to pick a fight in the first,
there was one dude who was at this bar
and Fullerton,
and he's being just belligerent.
He's being an asshole and this place
and,
and my buddy hammer,
he was the door guy at the time and the
southern and they're like,
come on.
And he's,
this guy's fucking getting all riled up.
And I'm standing there with hammer and
just looking at this dude.
And eventually the other tour guy comes
over and he's like,
hey,
you fucking dumb ass.
You're wearing the fucking tee shirt of
that guy right there.
So maybe you might want to shut the fuck
up.
It's this guy's wearing one of my
affliction shirts.
And the guy looks at the shirt and he
looks at me and he was like,
Oh shit,
this is stupid.
Getting your ass kicked.
Because you picked a fight with a guy
whose shirt you have on like you,
you are,
you're wearing a Josh Barnett shirt and
you don't know who Josh Barnett is.
Well,
and some,
a lot,
a lot of this shit comes from people
putting themselves into situations where
they have upped the ante to wear for
them not to follow through.
Is,
is going to bring about like a,
a huge internal conflict with them.
You know,
they're going to know that they raised
the stakes and then they had to back
down,
which I think is really hard for just
about anybody to deal with,
to get yourself to a point where you're
like,
yeah,
you know,
I'm in the right.
And then to,
to dial that back.
I mean,
people don't even want to really
apologize for anything,
let alone have to admit that they took
something too far.
It got to a point where they weren't
willing to go any further and they
realize they fucked up and then to fuck
and Tuck,
Tuck tail and leave again and back down.
And there's a lot of insecurity involved
in that.
There was a lot of insecurity probably
to get it at that point in the first
place,
which is why people that really know how
to fight don't have to go out there and
try to prove to somebody else that,
that they are capable or that look at,
hey everybody,
look at how,
how bad ass I am.
So you know,
when it was like for me,
I just,
I don't start fights,
you know?
I mean,
barring that,
maybe that the occasional moment where
someone I thought was being an asshole
or I thought they were being a shitty
person,
the reason they're being a shitty person
is because they thought that no one
would call them on it.
You know,
and for me to call them on,
it is more about there doesn't need to
be any conflict here tonight,
but you want to create it because you're
an insecure little prick.
So I'll,
I'll,
I'll be your huckleberry.
All right.
Now that you see that somebody was
willing,
now how much is it worth to you?
And of course it's,
it's almost,
it's never worth it to them.
And even people that have been all
fucking fired up and you know,
of course they're operating off of anger
and emotion and,
and of,
of upping something to a point where
they don't feel that they can back down.
Cause if you give someone an out,
especially in these kinds of things,
90% of the time they take it but a this,
that always that last word thing that
everybody wants,
they want to feel like it was winning
the fight to a lot of dickheads.
But you know when you,
sometimes you turn to somebody,
you go,
you don't know anybody that knows
anybody that knows anybody that knows
anybody that can kicked my ass.
So I don't know what you're going to do
right now or who you're going to call
it,
but it ain't going to fucking work.
Or it's just,
you know,
turn to somebody and you're like,
how many friends you got with you?
That ain't enough.
You know,
go get more because I don't know which
one you guys want to get involved.
But the first one that I can get my
hands on too,
I'm a fucking cripple you.
I'm a fuck you up.
I don't know if you guys can take me,
but I want to know how many of you I'm
going to take with me first.
Or my favorite is people nowadays don't
really,
so everything is the reduction to
violence.
Essentially.
Everything is a reduction to violence at
the base level.
Finally,
the final element is violence.
So what I'm saying is that,
so we create all the,
we create laws,
we create social norms,
we create all the customs and things to
honestly,
to avoid things getting to violence.
But even your simplest law is
essentially rooted in the element of
violence.
So,
okay.
Uh,
you,
you will use some,
some,
some law,
right?
Like a ticket of some sort and it's
like,
Whoa,
I'm going to find you for the thing.
I'm not going to pay it.
Oh,
okay.
Well then we're going to find you some
more.
I'm not going to pay that.
We're going to do this.
I'm not going to do that.
Well,
okay then if you're not going to pay the
thing,
you're not going to,
you're not going to do this and you're
not going to let your not going to,
oh,
well then what we're going to do is
we're going to arrest you.
No,
you're not.
At some point it reduces down to
violence.
So we're using violence all the time
too.
Or at least the con,
the for a lot of things for pretty much
everything.
You know,
in terms of social controls.
Eventually if someone doesn't want to
adhere to those controls in some way,
violence is the final solution.
It's what it's,
what it boils down to.
It is the basis for,
for all of our police and military and
even honestly it still exists within all
of us on a social level.
It's just that we have managed to take
that concept and put it on to something
else.
The law,
right?
Police,
something like that.
But the reality is is that if some guy
just at some point says,
you know,
I don't really give a fuck and you were
an asshole and I'm just going to wreck
you.
Okay,
you can sue them,
you can do this.
You can call the cops on him,
you can whatever.
But violence is going to happen whether
you want it to or not and whether this
person was in the right cause.
That's another thing is like violence in
and of itself.
Even if you're the winner.
Like I had to remember what philosopher
once said,
you know,
winning the dual doesn't mean that you
are correct.
It just means that you one,
you know,
that's a good point.
So tools.
Yeah,
but um,
uh,
so all these things are,
are,
you know,
customs norms,
all a lot of this stuff is to avoid
anything breaking down to violence
because you know,
you bump into someone,
you spill their drink and they turn in
and go,
hey man,
well that was fucked up.
And you turn them and you go,
you know what it was,
I'm sorry.
Or You could turn on me like,
you know what?
Fuck you.
Fuck me.
You spilled my drink.
I have,
I'm taking offense to this.
I now don't have my drink.
Who's going to make this right.
I don't really give a shit,
Huh.
That everything starts to escalate.
And as soon as,
as,
as one person takes a stand,
and if that other person rising to that,
to that next level to then,
and they raised it again,
eventually you get to a certain point,
it's like,
okay,
what,
where are we going with this?
Where is the solution?
Where does any of this lie ad it's,
you've,
you've stripped down all other options
until he got to a point where all you
got allowed yourselves was violence or
to completely re pull yourself entirely
out of that situation,
which a lot of people aren't
necessarily.
If it really,
really,
really got to that point,
they're not willing to do because that
was too much of the emotional maturity
to realize they've made a mistake or to
just not engage and not want to be a
part of it.
Yeah.
But then there's that psychological
thing of wanting to win.
What a weird battle of words.
Right?
Well,
and there's,
there's uh,
other complex things,
like if it was a males,
you know,
there's social hierarchy stuff.
Um,
if it was females,
their social eric,
our stuff between that.
If it's male on female,
it could be,
you know,
well there's always this side up.
If you're really super concerned about
what other people think or how you're
going to be perceived by others in a
group setting,
you know that that could also plan to a
factor which happens,
you know,
out and about on the town or whatever.
Your buddies always see you in this
situation or other people.
Everyone,
okay,
you got their attention now what are you
going to do?
And so if they see you completely
retreat,
everyone's like,
uh Huh.
All right.
Well that guy really wasn't what he said
he was
right,
right.
Yeah.
You're not down,
man.
Did you ever see that thing where Sean
Connery,
uh,
I was talking to Barbara Walters and she
asked him about hitting chicks.
Yeah,
I've seen it.
And he's like,
sometimes she gives them to lash word
[inaudible] from rough.
They have to shape more when you're
trying to get from one retro for Mark
Level Schmuck.
Yeah.
That's just sad.
Was just like,
uh,
she didn't know what the fuck she
thought she had them.
Yeah.
She thought it was over and he dug his
heels in.
He's impervious,
I guess,
you know.
But,
uh,
I
no common his body because he probably
fucked 15 different women that day.
And it was just like Carne from non
trench conversational.
We're having Kira do I need just from
Acura?
I'm Barbara.
I'm fucking Sean Connery.
James.
Look at the smile on his face and look
at my mustache bald.
I don't care.
I'm on them.
I'm a man's man.
Let's play.
Can we play it without getting pulled
off of Youtube?
A woman now.
And then as I remember you said you
don't do it with a clenched fist.
It's better to do it with an open hand.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
Remember that?
I really love that.
I haven't changed my opinion.
It's to slap a woman.
No,
I don't think it's good.
I don't think it's bad.
I don't think it's that bad.
I think that it depends entirely on the
circumstances and if it merits it,
oh,
oh.
What would merit it?
Well,
if you have tried everything else and
women are pretty good at it,
they can't leave it alone.
They know what they want to have the
last word.
Then you'd give them the last,
last one,
but they're not happy with the last one.
They want to share it again and get into
a really provocative situation.
Then I think you're absolutely right.
Wow.
Oh boy.
Oh,
that's so people get sean connery being
rude and aggressive.
Play that up.
Next.
What is,
what is he getting rude and aggressive
about it?
Do you work for the tabloid,
the National Enquirer or your wedding?
A jock strap on what?
I've knocked.
Not Tonight.
Okay.
That's why you're smiling.
I haven't dated too tight.
You probably knew you were going to be
here.
What?
You make another film director again?
Would you do another interview with me?
I wouldn't do a film.
Go.
Wow.
I don't know.
I'm trunk on the rear.
How are you?
Funny.
If that was right next to him,
it's ready to take some deck.
Honestly,
it didn't seem that rude or aggressive.
They just didn't like the question and
he fucked with them about it.
Yeah.
Well,
clickbait in any ways.
I personally do not put hands on women.
I'm not in the mind into that.
I also give her a chick tried to hit you
though.
Oh fuck yeah.
Are you kidding me?
No,
I've been to,
I've been chin checked while driving
once I have a like snack.
Oh that was cool that we had each other
and that's,
is that what it is?
Wants to get fucked hall.
You're not fucking her hard enough
judge.
Apparently not shit.
Put your boots on those wrestling shoes
he wore when you tap dance to a lace up
motherfucker put some uh,
some uh,
some tack them on my arms.
Make sure to get a good grip.
You might want to throw the mattress on
the ground.
Right.
You know,
so you could really like dig in.
I can tell sort of thing.
Really.
You can really trust bottom that thing
out.
Yeah man.
Like you will push up against a wall and
a,
your feet just on hardwood for,
that's what I'm thinking.
Right.
You just planking and just,
you know,
driving actually offers carpeting.
You had your bedroom like the stuff that
stain resistant.
Yeah.
It's got that grip on it per gripping.
Girls are like,
what the fuck is this?
Like why is your carpet show part fuck
up?
This is going to get real real in a
second,
but you're going to love me for it.
I,
no,
I've been,
I've been hit.
Uh,
I,
uh,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not like,
Oh,
you've been in abusive relationships and
not like that.
I mean it's just people,
it's frustrations and people not being
able to manage those.
I remember one,
uh,
this Gal,
she trains,
she fought and at one point and she used
to do all kinds of shit,
right to go.
You know what?
That is the most fucked up shit.
You really abusing the fact you know
your,
your gender and that you know that
you're a woman.
So I'm not going to do anything,
but you're going to do shit to me that
if you were a man,
I would just knock all your teeth out.
Like you,
you crossed so many lines and been so
disrespectful and,
and done things that are,
you know,
an invasion of personal space and
respect.
It's just like,
man,
that's just too much.
Like you went way to you while you're
driving?
Yeah.
What if you went out bad?
Have been hilarious.
A girl knows how to fight and you know
what?
The person,
well this one,
but the one that punched
me while I was driving didn't know how
to fight,
but uh,
yeah,
well,
you know,
it's like they say to what the what the
drunk guy,
he passes out and he's always the one
that doesn't get hurt.
Right.
So I would have been like,
and then the car was cheap anyway,
so I wouldn't have cared and she
probably would have got tossed to the
window.
But,
uh,
but I just remember her saying to me
this one time,
this the one that did train,
she's like,
you know what?
You don't fucking kills me.
I could,
I could just hit you as hard as I wanted
to.
I could do whatever and it wouldn't
fucking matter.
Cause you know,
cause you're,
you and I bought and I,
you're just so much to say we were
installed and I'm just like,
Jesus,
fuck,
why is that my fucking fault?
Right.
You know we're having a,
we have an argument about something and
you escalate it and then you're mad at
me because you couldn't beat me up.
At the end of it.
You got so mad that you can't kick my
ass and now that makes you matter.
Let me play armchair psychologist cause
I'm good at this.
What I would think is that a gal like
that,
first of all,
she probably enjoys having a certain
amount of physical power over people and
went,
Shit escalates.
She wants that violence to be real.
She wants it to be a real threat coming
from her,
which is why she probably started
fighting in the first place.
Now when she's fighting,
when she's arguing with you,
all the sudden she's in this fucked up
situation where what she's worked for
her whole life is to become the scary
girl.
Or the girl could fuck people up.
A girl who's like literally a threat
physically,
she could probably knock a lot of dudes
out,
right?
But she's confronted with a giant former
UFC heavyweight champion and she's like,
God dammit,
I doesn't work that,
that psychology can absolutely hold true
for this one particular girl.
Um,
for her,
I think it was a matter of not being
able to,
you know,
having this frustration about not being
able to get the outcome that they
wanted,
um,
and having what they would feel is no
recourse to get me to,
to come to term tom come to their terms
and their way.
And so she uses physical violence,
never used physical violence,
never worried about that then,
uh,
Nah,
you know what it was,
it just insecurity,
it's insecurity and it was just like,
how is that even,
why,
why?
For one,
you know,
this,
this girl,
uh,
I was with her for a long time.
You know,
I haven't,
this one was a long time ago.
My most recent one on the other hand,
that one,
I've actually seen use violence before.
Um,
and it's just like,
how to me,
it's just like,
even with,
with arguing,
we would get into these arguments and
someone would make you know,
statement a and I'd say,
okay,
well,
uh,
I don't think St Manet holds true
because of these reasons.
And then we'd start going and then all
of a sudden statement a is get straw man
into something else.
And then,
no,
no.
You can't leave statement a because
you're basing your arguments on that.
We're not talking about statement b.
That's,
that's a whole different scenario
altogether.
This argument isn't,
is going nowhere now.
Now it's getting circular and you keep
taking me away from the original
argument to begin with to start hitting
you with six years ago you said this to
me and stuff like that.
It would be,
it'd be something on,
I dunno,
she turned into a gigantic Marxists.
SJW So yeah.
While you were dating her,
yes.
She turned sjws Social Justice Warrior,
Ladies and gentlemen,
if you're an online loan,
it would just be like,
well that,
okay,
hold on.
That doesn't make sense.
I don't,
I don't know your,
your logic here.
I don't think falls,
you know,
being correct turned into this,
like she didn't start out doing this.
Uh,
I think it existed,
you know,
she's from,
she went to Berkeley.
So,
but nonetheless,
it wasn't something that I ever saw,
especially to begin with.
It didn't seem like that was what I was
in store for until one day.
You know,
I look over and I'm like,
Huh,
bass copy tall.
Well,
yeah,
I think reading Marx is interesting and
I think it's worthwhile to understand
some of his,
his arguments.
And I think he's got some interesting
critiques of capitalism,
especially back in its day with it,
with this industrialism,
uh,
industrial society at that time.
But he doesn't understand people at all.
His solutions are fucking hackneyed and
you know,
he's coming from a very interesting
position because he doesn't even,
he as a person doesn't even stick to his
own,
his own shit,
you know,
but in any ways.
So we're having these arguments and then
it would turn to a pejorative and I'm
like,
well,
okay,
why are you attacking me?
I'm not attacking you.
I'm not even being angry about your
statement.
I just you,
you made statement a so I don't believe
in it.
I don't,
I don't think that that's correct.
So we're having a discussion,
but now it became a personal attack once
even gets to that,
let alone someone,
even back in the day talking about,
oh,
it really upsets me that uh,
no matter how angry you know,
my,
whatever,
if I hit you or did this,
it wouldn't matter because you're you.
It's like,
well,
both of these statements come from the
same,
same.
Both of those scenarios come from the
same place.
It's like,
well now you're trying,
you're attacking me,
the individual.
Because if you're going to do that,
you aren't thinking about me as the
person that's,
no,
no.
I got your back through heaven and hell,
I will kick the gates of hell down and
kill everyone there.
If I got to the four year,
they're there.
They want to devalue a,
they want to devalue me,
the person,
because they,
they feel attacked in some way.
They feel like they're,
they're so attached to their,
to their statement,
to whatever that may be,
which has some attachment to maybe what
they feel is their existence.
That to re to change that is dangerous.
To haul it outright wrong would be an
even bigger problem.
And I mean,
you know,
I,
it's just like this stuff would start
showing up at the house.
And so I'm like,
all right,
I'm going to start doing research on
marks and angles and all this different
stuff.
And then as I would go further and
further and further down the rabbit
hole,
I come back and I go,
oh,
okay.
So this argument stems from this and
this and this and this and this.
And they're like,
no,
it doesn't like,
wow.
Okay.
Uh,
why,
why do you think people operate?
Like what,
what do you think their whole reasoning
is?
You know,
we get into these arguments about
capitalism and capitalism is a neutral
system.
Ask you this.
What is it about social justice warriors
are left wing people that were Marxism
is so attractive to them.
Uh,
well for one it's,
it's this idea of equity.
Like this sameness,
like everybody,
nobody is being left behind and no one
is,
is becoming greater than anybody else.
Uh,
it's also the idea,
I like to think of it in,
I think a lot of these young people look
at it as grow mom's house,
mom and dad's house.
So when your mom and dad's house,
someone does your laundry,
someone cooks your food,
you know,
you always just show up.
You got a place to live,
uh,
you know,
the TV turns on and then they stable
government should become mom and dad
wants you.
Exactly.
So they want mom and dad's house to
exist forever.
So it's just like they can run off and
do whatever they want to do for food.
There's plenty of money for shelter.
We just need to spend it.
Right.
Redistribution of wealth.
Right,
exactly.
Because if you exceed that system more
than they deem that you should have,
then you should give it to somebody
else.
And it's like,
well,
how do you think I got this?
Oh my God,
how many?
I'm sorry to interrupt you.
Go ahead.
Let's just like,
how do you think I got this?
Uh,
people can say,
well,
it was you got it through you and
inherited it.
Okay,
that does happen.
I could also have got it through hard
work and dedication and some,
some guile and some smarts and made it
happen for myself.
Does that somehow mean that I had to do
it at the expense of someone else?
Not necessarily shitty argument.
Right.
That's the,
but that's the argument that they keep
bringing us.
But if you're successful,
you did it on the bits all grant.
It's all grift.
Yeah.
What do you think?
Why would,
this is what I wanted to ask back from
someone else is an interesting thing
too.
It's like if someone agrees to do a job,
if their skill set is limited in such a
way that they were owned,
that they were capable of doing this job
at this moment.
Now of course,
if you're asking me,
they probably,
they have a potential to do more than
that.
As long as they're willing to invest
back in themselves and find another
skill or expand that skill.
You know there's always possibility for
growth within a human being,
within their lot in life,
whatever that is and that that could be
transferred into work could be
transferred into a personal goals.
I mean it's all about how you value
things also.
So this person gets into this job
working,
making widgets for this guy who invented
this widget.
This guy invented the widget,
the argument that okay,
the worker deserves just as much as the
guy that invented it.
It's like well hold on.
Without the guy that invented the
widget,
you have no job.
Like all of these people that are
working out,
working underneath them get would have
nothing.
They would have zero,
there would be no widget to build.
And the guy that made the widget also
has the most responsibility because he
had to come up with the money to produce
the widget to be able to hire the people
to make the widget,
to then market the widget to do all
these
things to the widget to get it out there
to make it successful enough to then
support more people.
And that doesn't necessarily mean it's
on the back of that other person.
Because you could also say,
well,
is everything on the back of the guy
that made the widget?
I mean,
do you just,
his idea is not worth it.
Is,
is not,
can't be belonged to him because he
created it.
We,
we should take it for us,
even though we never,
we did not come up with it.
We never created it.
We didn't even have the facilities to
make to created and didn't invent it are
the ones who want to define how much
this guy should get for inventing it
versus how much they share.
And I would get into arguments with my
ex about,
she's like,
oh,
I think all businesses should be ops and
my thing.
You're like,
what does that mean?
Well cooperative where everybody is
getting an equal share and into the
business itself.
Yeah,
I would say it is hilarious and also
because I would say all businesses can
be co ops.
There is no one stopping a business from
being a co op.
We know it stops businesses from being a
co op.
If somebody doesn't want it to be a co
op or a,
someone decides,
well that doesn't,
I can't do it that way so it won't make
as much sense for me to create a co op
situation as it would to not or a colab
sounds nice and enforced.
Co op does not sound nice.
Of course club sounds nice if like say
if you and I live on a block and we say,
Hey,
we got this fucking patch of land.
Let's start a garden started a little
small farm.
Correct.
We'll just have a little co op here.
Right.
All right,
cool.
Great.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
But that's everybody doing volunteer and
says,
Josh Barnett,
is this the Josh Barnett Farm?
Yeah.
Well you're going to have to turn this
into a co op and you're like,
what the fuck I am.
Well,
we're going to put you in jail.
Exactly.
And then it's,
then it comes back down to violence.
Here's the question.
This is what I kept meaning to ask
before I forget.
Do you think that the,
what do you think the numbers are of the
people that are involved in these ideas
that have never competed in anything?
Now that's,
my ex girlfriend is a professional
fighter and she fights in tour.
However,
the idea of the meritocracy,
of being a fighter,
it seems it's not,
I don't think it's lost on her.
I just think that she,
she doesn't like the way it's worked out
for her and that makes her an upset.
Whereas for me,
I found success as being a fighter and
it sometimes it would appear that she
would be,
she would be upset at me for what I was
able to do and somehow think that maybe
I was less deserving or somehow,
um,
it's an exception that who knows what,
but the reality is,
is like I can sit back and go,
oh,
Mark Hunt just made $800,000.
Her thought might,
it might be more,
let's say if we're,
we're just,
I'm making this up.
I'm not saying that she said this,
you know,
he's like,
well,
why does he deserve $800,000?
Why I make a $4,000 or $5,000 or
whatever.
I've seen people say that,
right?
It's just like,
okay,
well I could think of plenty of reasons.
And then he draws more tickets.
He's got a better record.
He's,
he's one,
he's a k one she champ or whatever,
you know,
at the end of the day,
if any in New Zealand.
Right,
right.
And if he's selling more tickets than
you are,
then he gives it,
he deserves a greater percentage of that
money.
Now,
now you come to me and I'd be like,
well,
I beat Mark Hunt.
Right?
But what's her argument for that when
you say that?
Uh,
her argument for that would be that,
you know,
this other person isn't any more
deserving than,
so everybody should get paid the same.
So Jon Jones,
Fides,
Daniel Cormier,
Yay.
Huge fight.
Everybody on the undercard gets a fair
share.
Well either that or just like,
well,
I deserve more than this.
And it's,
and my argument would always be when,
when,
when she was upset about what she may be
getting paid here or there and some of
this,
I'd go,
well,
look,
you know,
for,
for this,
for what we're trying to accomplish and
for what,
what is available in these markets,
that's not a bad payday.
Well,
that sucks.
No,
I agree with you.
You should make more money,
but we can't,
it's not available.
So we have to deal with what we have for
me.
And then I would look at something like
Mark Hunt and be like,
well,
I beat mark comp.
It's so what?
I'm more glad that Mark Hunt was able to
create an opportunity to make $800,000
so therefore if he can make $800,000 now
the potential for me do that exists as
well.
And it's just similar to like the old
Gina Carano thing where everyone got on
a train about wanting to be Gina Carano
fucked junior crunch,
not even that good,
and blah,
blah,
blah.
All this hate at Gina Carano.
When the reality is like,
okay,
well even if you beat Gina Carano,
you're not going to get what Gina Carano
gets.
You're not going to get that and people
aren't going to like you just as much or
more.
It's really not about any of that.
The only thing you can control is
yourself.
At the end of the day,
you can only control yourself.
You can,
you only you can can work to try and
increase or you're in determine your
value in terms of what you're trying to
sell,
but isn't part of selling today at least
talk shit.
Some of it
seems to be like because of honor his
proficiency at it.
Yeah.
And his massive financial success
because of it
wins.
He wins all the time.
He won belts,
he made very bold statements and then
went out in one.
Um,
another person could then go and talk
shit.
Maybe they win and people still don't
care as much.
Right.
You know,
you can't force people to care.
And what makes them care is a metric
that you just can't define.
You know,
there's one way of doing it is to make
them all hate you.
But when you lose your,
your,
what's going to happen is you're going
to drop off.
Often everything that you gained will be
lost.
But as they hate you,
as you continue to win,
they're going to be more in incited to
watch you fight.
They're going to be more interested to
Big Guy like randy coture,
everybody loves.
And even when he loses,
everybody loves in the same.
Sure.
And,
and you know how that combination comes
about is
magic.
Well,
I think with randy,
it's sincerity,
but I think,
look,
look at Kevin Lee and Michael
[inaudible] from this past weekend.
Perfect example of like a few of these
guys put together talking shit to each
other at a press conference.
They get in a scuffle at a press
conference and all of a sudden everybody
cares about the result of this fight.
And then the fight has a controversial
ending and now it's even more crazy.
And now there's a lot of eyes on Kevin
Lee and Michael Essa
that three,
four months ago,
just saying both guys are super
talented,
chef guys have some really good wins.
And um,
I think Kevin Lee's get some real
fucking potential.
But people weren't really talking about
on the way they are now.
So a lot of other fighters are going to
look at that and go,
yeah,
that's what I gotta do.
I've gotta Talk Shit on Gina Carano or
I've got to talk shit on.
A lot of that is,
is what,
what the Gina Carano thing,
that was insecurity and that was also,
she was a superstar and the only thing
was,
and people want it,
they thought that they could have what
she had by taking it from her.
And it's like,
well,
that's not actually how it works.
You can,
you can beat her and that'll definitely
do something for you and by fighting her
it's going to elevate your status but
not the same status.
I know Holly Holm,
you're your own knocks out Rhonda.
Sure.
I mean she devastated Rhonda,
right?
She was the first one.
Right.
Is undefeated.
It looks like a tank that's coming at
her and holly wines of head kicking her
and knocking her out.
I mean,
holly is still a really highly respected
professional fighter,
but you mean it's not the same?
It doesn't have the same.
Well,
it also did something for her.
Her accolades coming in,
so she's just heavily touted boxing
champion.
That boxing championship looks more
interesting now after she goes and she
wins the MMA belt too.
Let me ask you this,
why don't they set up Cyborg versus her?
Isn't that the fight Cyborg versus Holly
Holm?
Is Holly Holm drawn to me?
I don't know.
A lot of people thought Holly Holm
should have won that fight.
It was a very close fight and Duran to
me definitely hit her twice after the
bell.
Really significant and should have been
a penalization.
So why the fuck is holly fighting?
I know she just fought [inaudible] but
as soon as Megan Anderson dropped off,
if holly could take it,
I mean she didn't have,
I love,
she was not injured.
It maybe she is.
Who knows?
She might be managers.
Yeah.
Who knows lookers.
Who knows?
Who knows what,
but that's the fight.
That's an interesting fight.
Holly versus Cyborg is the fucking
fight.
It would be a great fight.
I think people would be interested to
watch it,
but for sure not the fight it's being
made and say we don't Tonya average
juror stepping up and fighting a Cyborg
and Stan.
Yeah,
and short notice,
you know,
but Tanya's a Gamer,
she's very tough.
She will fight anybody.
He would fight the fight because of
that,
because she's so tough.
That's what makes it exciting.
But you know,
cyborgs.
That giant person is,
she was massive.
She bought for explosive,
which to me,
explosiveness in women's MMA is a
massive difference between success and
not like if you're,
if you're super explosive,
like that usually makes a massive,
a big difference.
In terms of your success rate,
did you see cyborgs barn with Claressa
shields two time Olympic gold medal in
boxing and hanging in there?
Man.
I mean,
she's an outbox for sure,
but not by much.
She landed some good shots.
She's still game and moving forward,
fighting and throwing stuff.
Dangerous and dangerous against a super
high level boxer.
A girl that's even arguably bigger than
her too.
Yeah,
and lightening fast.
but watching shields,
like we've set things up and use that
jab like,
dude,
I just want to
learn some fucking sprawl
specialization.
You know?
That's the thing about boxing and the
connor and mayweather fight is it's the
specialization of,
of a boxer versus the MMA person.
I would say the MMA fighters,
the superior fighter,
right.
When you,
when you start to me the most open and
he,
the most,
even playing field is the one that has
at least rules.
But by funneling that down to those
specific skill sets with boxing,
you create a specialized athlete.
While there are skills with boxing that
will transfer to mma,
even just in terms of boxing,
uh,
the,
the timing and the footwork that you
might use in boxing isn't necessarily
what you would use in mma and uh,
and vice versa.
Distance.
Right.
But so I see that,
you know,
it would be great if conor goes out
there and wins.
It would make mma look that much bigger,
you know,
but uh,
and he's got the power and he,
he's a,
he's a great athlete and he's got good
timing and accuracy.
I just don't see him being able to get
flush on mayweather the way that it's
going to be needed.
It seems highly unlikely unless he old
school Bernard Hopkins Hymns,
you know,
remember Bernard used to fight,
he's to clinch guys and just sear.
Sure.
Off muffin clinch outside.
He was just straight defensive.
But do you really think that boxing
referee's are going to let that happen?
I don't know.
And there's going to be even more
eyeballs on conner to diminish that
aspect because they're going to be
expecting him to do stuff like that
anyways there or you know there's,
I'm sure there's already,
I've heard that there are elements in
the contract about kicks and things like
that.
They have to put that in there.
That would have to put that in there,
some sort of side dish to haul off and
kick him and that's it.
You lose all your money.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
But I feel like if you,
if you looked at conner and like his
skill set,
like what's what he's capable of doing.
Like overall I could see how he would
think like man,
it's just striking.
I feel like I could probably get close
enough.
Yeah,
I can get off on anybody.
Sure.
But that level that floyd mayweather is
at like to have zero professional boxing
fights and to spar with him and you know
also from Congress perspective he's
thinking I this is a chance to be a
hero.
This is another opportunity to be a
I have hardly anything to lose,
if at all.
And all to gain the potential of
winning.
I also have a big payday winter lose,
so everything works out towards a win
win situation for him.
You know,
it would've been great if connor could
get,
get this stipulation will only box,
but we were mma gloves.
Yeah.
Well a floyd has had issues with his
hands in the past,
which is why he almost exclusively
where's winning gloves in the there.
So that would never happen.
Thick fat glass.
And I think they're fighting with 10
ounce gloves too.
It's a big glove.
Tends not eight.
No,
I don't think so.
I think the,
the agreed upon weight was 10 see if
that's the case.
Is that the case?
Yeah.
Ah,
ah,
I'm surprised.
Interesting.
I would've thought eights something a
little bit like what?
147 pounds
or 150
fight.
55 okay.
And I think I thought 60 was the cutoff,
but [inaudible] 68 or one 74 where they
go to 10.
Huh.
But uh,
either way much bigger than four.
Which is what gs accustomed to.
Yeah.
And I feel like if,
but look man,
it's still,
you know,
I had a conversation with a buddy of
mine who's a really good jujitsu black
belt and he was gonna fight in mma and
he had very little sparring in terms of
like mma sparring or very little,
uh,
kickboxing sparring,
almost no strike king.
And uh,
I said,
you know how you can do things to be
bull on the ground where you get some
guy who does know what he's doing,
you can just do whatever the fuck you
want to him.
I go,
this guy's,
they can do that too.
Standing up like you gotta be careful.
Like you can't get this in your head
that you're awesome at something.
So you're awesome at everything,
right.
Cause the,
the type of mentality that a person has
to become,
whether it's a championship level mma
fighter or a boxers that that focus,
that intense focus.
Like sometimes guys get twisted and they
think that because of my Brazilian
Jujitsu champion,
I can be a kickboxing champion.
I could be an MMA champion,
do whatever the fuck I want to do,
but the road is long,
man,
the road is long.
People forget all that they went through
to acquire such a set of skills to get
there in the first place.
And I understand that,
you know,
a highly,
highly specialized Jujitsu or wrestler
can go out there and experience success
in mma right away.
However,
like you said,
they might come across that guy who is
so good on their feet that they can do
the whatever they want to to that guy
and just leave them clueless and when,
or does he take them down or there's
that where that there's that person that
you're just not able,
you take them down once,
twice,
but they could keep your Mac their feet.
Now all of a sudden you're tired.
You've been pushing so much harder
because you can't fight Eh,
a,
a plan B or,
or in this other plane you have to fight
within the plane that you're an expert
because you put all your marbles in one
basket,
not a mighty mouse.
So you can kind of do it all in any
forum.
Your a Damien Maia who's learned how to
kickbox got really good at it,
but when you fight Damien Maia,
you know,
real clear what his plan is
for sure.
And even still at Damien Maia has,
has learned to create striking that that
helps mitigate other people's striking
so that he can get his best game off.
Yeah.
So that's still a type of standup work
that he's working on within that has
been specialized for mma as he fights in
the UFC.
Do you agree though
that a guy like conor mcgregor would
have way more like,
I feel like the odds of floyd beating
conor are extremely high in a boxing
match and the nine high 90% sure.
Right.
But the odds of connor beating floyd an
MMA match or 100 pretty much.
Pretty much 199.9999999 Connie would
have to like really fuck up.
He'd have to get chin checked.
Yeah.
Doing something stupid now he would just
not kicking,
right?
Yeah.
He would kick the shit out of his leg.
This isn't,
this isn't a fight about who's a better
fighter.
Right.
This is a fight about who's a better
boxer.
Yeah.
And the idea that Congress is going to
step in and just clang floyd with a
straight left is almost as ridiculous as
the idea that flow is going to step into
an mma fight and catch connor with a big
punch and knock them out.
Ray Mercer,
Tim,
Tim Silvia,
Silvia style.
I say it's more like floyd mayweather
jumping in that cage and armbarring car.
You know,
it's like that.
Yeah.
Catching him in a fucking rolling teen.
Fucking victor role and do a knee bar.
Get hit him with an MNR.
He's been catch him with one of them
crazy heel hooks,
like you know floyd and his heel hooks.
Ah,
well when,
that was one of the crazy things with
James.
Tony fought randy coture like there's
all these people speculating like how
much James Tony had been training mma
and then he got to see him do some stuff
with like an MMA trainer and you're
like,
oh,
okay.
He's not barely doing this.
He's barely doing this.
He does that.
He stopped.
He doesn't know anything.
Well,
this is crazy.
And then randy just goes out there.
The angle,
the single and the ankle just falls over
in that end of that night.
Yeah.
Low single randy on top.
That's a wrap.
Randy was merciful though.
I mean you punched him a few times and
then just choked him.
Yeah.
Randy isn't really,
he wasn't known for being a particularly
vicious competitor.
You have a feeling you probably would
have treated that situation slightly
differently.
Yeah.
I would've tried to term absolutely limb
from limb.
Not,
not,
not because of any particular personal
animosity,
just because I go out there to wreck
people because I want to make sure that
if I'm winning,
I'm winning.
But if you had a guy like,
like a James Tony on the ground who came
in from pr,
professional boxing,
no one may fights,
would you have it in your mind that you
need to prove a point?
Did you have in your mind just finishing
when you can smash them any way
possible?
You know,
I chop his leg,
whatever,
shoot a double blow through them,
get on top and then just start doing
whatever is available for such a nice
guy and such a well spoken guy.
You enjoy hurting people in a very
disturbing way.
I,
it's what I'm good at.
It's what I was,
that's what I,
I learned at an early age that it was
something that I excelled at.
I asked you just in partly to see your
response because I knew that you're
going to get worked up about it and he
were to think about smashing him and
like what you would do.
Like it's seen in your eyes thinking
about taking them down.
I love,
that's part of the reason why by leaving
fighting I know was going to be tough
not competing because I love going out
there and in some way it is.
I was explaining this,
I was actually out of philosophical
lecture the other night and uh,
cause I'm a big fan of philosophy.
What was the philosophical,
well,
this,
this lecture was on 16 part series on a
America and it was this last one.
This friend of mine hit me up.
She goes,
hey,
this thing's going down,
uh,
at this,
this,
this school.
So,
hey,
why don't,
why don't we go check it out?
All right,
cool.
And so
it had something to do with the futurism
and I forget what else,
but as the lecture was going on,
people would chime in and say stuff.
And so at one point,
I'm listening to some of these,
these arguments that I'm just going,
man,
you just don't really,
you don't understand people that well.
I mean,
every,
a lot of these arguments always come
from some idea of a base motivation from
somebody.
Like the idea that all capitalism is
theft.
It's like,
well,
you know,
you don't have to be a horrible person
to operate successfully within a
capitalist system.
Just as much as just because you create
a communist system doesn't necessarily
make you benevolent.
Because as you will look in the Soviet
Union and as you've had,
um,
uh,
Robert,
our,
uh,
Jordan Peterson on here,
and he'll tell you all of the elements
of,
of the brutality of communist systems.
And then of course,
I remember being in the 80s and even
seeing a slides from,
uh,
one of my teachers who was over in the
Soviet Union and sneaking photos out of
the USSR because they didn't want any
photos of,
of living conditions and all these sorts
of things,
bread lines,
all that stuff brought back to the
western world because they felt it would
make them look bad.
Well,
of course,
because it did,
you know,
and people were entrenched in these
systems and abusing these systems to
their benefit,
just like Paul or politicians abused our
system to their benefit,
just like all human beings will abuse
the system to its benefit when given the
chance to do so,
either out of selfishness to the point
of maliciousness or even just direct
maliciousness.
So the human element is the,
the key process in all systems there.
They're pretty much the cause of all
systems failing.
And they always will be.
But when you try to create some other
roundabout idea,
you try to assign,
uh,
you know,
these other crazy concepts as to why or
you create these micro group I
ideologies and you distill and distill
and distill and you constantly create
like with,
with Marxism,
it's a conflict theory.
So there's always has to be some sort of
a presser.
There always has to be a conflict.
And you know,
a lot of human beings aren't out there
trying to oppress people.
They're just trying to get theirs and or
you know,
creating their little tribes and
creating what they,
you know,
to use a overused word,
safe space for themself that which they
understand this area.
They understand these demarcations about
this group and these people and this
thing and even this area of land in
which you live in,
you know,
the idea of going,
I know I'm going off on a tangent here
from our original discussion,
but the idea of like personal property
and you know,
you have your fence line around let's
say a piece of property.
I was walking through Joshua Tree and
looking at all this stuff and pondering
some things and,
and you know that,
that that property line isn't just about
me owning this and keeping other people
out and being and looking at it and
someone wants to say,
Oh,
you just want to be selfish and own and
be greedy and dominate something.
And it's like,
well actually think about it this way.
That line is the same as an extension
from my own personal space.
You know,
I know you so fuck,
you know,
you can get right in my personal space
and I don't care because we've already
vetted each other.
We've already had a relationship.
W I,
I,
I have a good understanding of who you
are as Joe Rogan and,
and your being in the world and you
understand me to a degree as well as
Josh Barnett versus some guy just shows
up at your house versus some guys,
some things,
some,
anything that you don't know you don't
know is,
so you have this fence line is,
is what you're doing is you're,
you're creating this space that is just
in a person.
It's just an extension of your own
personal bubble of your own personal
safe space.
And so within that you feel like you've
vetted it,
you know these rocks,
you know these planets,
you understand the,
the pluses and minuses of this area that
exists.
And so within this place of existence,
you can be your most authentic self
without any concern of the rest of the
world.
Now if somebody's something was to come
and want to cross that line,
you'd want to say,
well,
I don't know what it is yet.
So I want to vet that source and then
say,
okay,
yeah,
it's okay.
I'll allow you into my,
into my space,
into my area.
And so now you too can also be open to
the vulnerability that I'm giving you
because that's what it is.
You know,
our personal space is about our
vulnerability,
about the ability for someone else to,
you know,
interact with us physically as well as
emotionally.
And so even just having your little
cabin with your little fence,
that little thing isn't just again,
have that right.
It is a Marxist ideas of no private
property and acre.
Yeah.
There's not like a lot of full on old
school marxists anymore.
They're all pretty much neo marxists
from the,
as as Peterson and other people have
described from the Frankford schools,
uh,
you know,
permeating into the academia and,
and going after the,
the superstructure instead of the base.
I think this is an undeniable aspect
that you talked about before were with
your ex girlfriend at least,
or with some people like that.
We don't even have to single out her
that people that are not successful in
this,
in the competition of life seek to
diminish the success of those around
them.
And yes.
Yeah.
Which is,
so it's,
it's the other thing about that is the
value that you create where,
where,
what is your values were,
what is your value system and,
and how is that going to influence you?
So if you,
if your value system is based on
external elements,
like,
you know,
Nisha talks about the,
the danger of unchecked envy,
envy being a life affirming element.
You know,
if I envy Joe Rogan and his podcast,
which I do,
I can see that,
well joe was able to create this
podcast.
So the possibility exists.
So for,
for a person to create a podcast and
they'd be successful with and expand
from there on out so that mv can drive
me to then work towards it because I
know it's a possibility.
Having unchecked envy would be to be
angry at you for having that podcast
and thinking that,
well,
you know,
he's got this thing and I want that
thing.
How do I deserve it too?
And I don't have dessert.
It burn it to the ground.
Why?
Because you're so upset about it.
But that's the lowest of self esteems
right?
The people that not only do they not
think they can't compete,
they don't want anyone to be successful
because they don't think they're ever
going to be every day without social,
with,
through,
throughout social media.
People are seeing Mandy manufactured
manicured interpretations of life and
thinking and weighing themselves against
that.
So that's just one example of how you
are using these external forces to
determine your value systems are putting
value on things that are beyond your
control or,
or putting value in areas that are
unnecessary,
that are actually harmful to you.
And so people,
if I had to just walk away from
everything,
like my muscle cars and all that stuff,
and I know,
I know it's a horrible thought.
I have a,
I have some projects that are,
that are going to be to completion here
soon that are,
I'm just so looking forward to,
are you still driving the challenge of
though that your main mode of
transportation is?
My daily driver,
but I'm replacing it with a 75 formula
firebird with four 55 that I punched out
the four 70 automatic overdrive trans
and hotchkiss suspension,
wilwood brakes all the way around on it.
It's going to be fucking great.
Nine inch board in the back.
Speaking of which Gabriel Iglesias was
just on Jay Leno's garage.
Yeah.
And he's got a dope Burt Reynolds
fucking smoking the bandit Trans Am.
Yeah,
they do build them up for the new
Camaro's.
Yeah,
he was loving it.
But is that what his,
his,
his from the delta,
the new Camaro.
I just saw the picture of him with
standing with Jay next to the car.
That car looks,
it is a,
it's a sweet car.
I've seen him at Sema car that doesn't
impress girls at all.
That's only for Liga,
that fucking thing.
So that's based on the one on the left.
The one on the left is a real old one.
27 78 has a brand new one.
Holy Shit.
So there's,
Oh my God.
They put a front new new nose piece on
it and they put the Shaker scoop.
They put it and this one he put it,
they put an ls three and because they do
all this stuff for folks,
folks who don't know it doesn't even
exist anymore.
I wonder if they could do that with the
Zl one.
I'll do it with anyone.
Zl One of the fastest cars to ever lap
the nurburgring yes.
Faster than the corporate zero six
fascinating.
It's incredible what we're doing with
cars.
But if I had to give all the shit out
now,
if I have to give all this shit up,
I would hate it.
That's amazing.
Love it.
Yeah.
It's a burt burt reynolds addition.
Holy Shit.
He signed it.
Yeah.
So,
but if I did truth be told,
I look at the hearse shifter as hard as
a rock truth.
Truth be told,
I can,
I can get rid of all these things.
I can be free of all of that stuff and
still have a life that makes me highly,
uh,
happy craves Nancy.
I know.
I don't want to,
I just want to get crazy extreme.
Those Marxists.
They're fucking with your head man to
change in your value.
You know,
they want to take my firebird and my gt
500,
all that stuff,
but uh,
and I can't help it that my car has more
boosts in yours.
Yeah,
you can't.
But,
uh,
the thing is,
is that it's where I put my values were
what,
what is valuable to me and what's
valuable and living and being so for
someone else,
they put these things on other stuff and
they,
they give responsibility.
What they end up doing is transferring
that power to external sources.
And when you start working off of
external sources as your,
your value is your value system,
then you've taken away that power from
yourself.
Right.
And so,
well,
there's also the rejection.
I have a rejection of the idea that you
can enjoy people's creations.
I think of a car is a creation.
Yeah.
I'm going to think of it a lot of ways
is like a mass produced piece of art.
Sure.
You know what someone's done in creating
like that?
Uh,
that new a,
what is it?
The Demon?
Yeah.
Dodge demon.
Right.
That challenge or that we'll go nine
sixties.
It goes zero to 60 in less than three
seconds.
And it's a production car.
You can't drive it.
If it's colder than 15 degrees out,
he can't drive it.
It's like,
it's such a,
it's such a fucked up car.
But like that to me is I'm fascinated
that someone chose to make it.
I liked,
if I look at that the same way I look at
them doing space exploration,
like,
oh,
that's all going to trickle down to
regular cars.
Sure.
You know,
they're going to figure out how to make
tank out of this.
Sure.
And that's the thing is that these
things wouldn't exist if people weren't
driven to,
uh,
to express their will,
to power and grow,
to want to be their greatest version of
themselves,
to create a greater thing than the last
thing to,
to push that envelope.
Right.
And while it's not always going to be
successful,
it's the idea of creating something
greater and greater,
greater.
Now,
I mean,
there's the argument with,
with science that there's always a,
you know,
is it,
uh,
should,
or could,
uh,
you know,
of course there is an element of ethics.
It has to play into that I think that
you need to be aware of and is also with
objects you don't want to get obsessed
and fixated on that.
Rejects,
but it doesn't mean you can't enjoy a
new laptop.
Right.
Well,
and I think that a lot of these,
these new like champagne socialist type
folks,
they,
they enjoy,
they enjoy these,
the new lab laptops
in the new iphones and all that stuff
and it's,
they love all the modern conveniences of
the capitalist country that we live in.
And you know,
if someone wanted to sit down and talk
to me about the,
the danger they out the elements of our
society,
of our capitalist economy and how it,
it is an,
is an issue,
the issues within it now.
Totally.
I get it.
No,
our system is fucked up and a lot of
ways,
don't get me wrong,
but by replacing it with,
with,
uh,
you know,
some sort of a Marxist system now you're
just asking for,
I mean,
we already have enough trouble with
people in power being unsuitable and in
a sense like us being hiving of very
ineffective way of really effecting our
political system and creating change
within it and having things taken away
or new laws created,
altered,
like it's so impossible.
Right.
But it's like,
it's a system that works outside of us,
even though we're supposedly the ones
that can quick can control it.
But,
uh,
it,
you create a,
uh,
a communist system,
right?
You create a full states,
a secured system,
you really have no ability to affect
that,
right.
Without some sort of a violent
revolution,
which,
uh,
doesn't,
not probably in your best interest,
uh,
with the way technology and military and
all that stuff.
I mean,
it's just,
no one wants to things to get to that
point.
And so,
so they always preach a ramp down
version of it though,
because like the,
well,
there's never any true,
by the way,
there's never been a true,
a true communist system or they're never
been true Marxism.
It's always the fucking no true scotsman
fallacy.
It's like,
it never happened.
This never happened yet.
It's like,
what the fuck do you think the,
the,
the Soviets were doing?
What do you think that the malice,
they all thought they were doing it.
Right.
You know,
but it,
and even then when you go to look at
China nowadays,
like,
well,
they got all these capitalists elements
within it that are making their economy
just fucking flush with money,
so flushed with money that they're,
they're like,
oh,
I don't want to give it to the
government.
So they send it all over to Vancouver
and buy up all these houses and stuff
like this and then have their teenage
kid lived there all over Hollywood,
even Bel Air.
Right.
A lot of,
a lot of Asian money,
a lot of money from Saudi Arabia as
well.
Right.
And you know,
Saudi Arabia,
you know,
you're talking theocracy.
Yeah.
And they're worried about their money
getting taken away over there.
So they drive by real estate over here.
Yeah.
And also it's very valuable,
like keeps going up.
It's a good investment and when you're
making trillions of dollars by sucking
oil out of the ground.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
And,
you know,
at the end of the day,
um,
uh,
the thing about all this stuff is that,
that the,
when the,
if you give people the most opportunity
to be free,
you're also giving the most opportunity
to be shitty.
And you have to accept that.
You just have to accept that some people
are just going to be fucking assholes.
Some people are going to be Shitty,
some people are going to try and create
a system that,
that you're not gonna like it's gonna
reward others for things you don't think
it should,
but you're always going to get those
hedge fund dudes.
You're always going to get those guys
who have those gigantic estates in the
Hamptons and fuck people,
you know,
and my girlfriend,
uh,
graduated with a,
with a physics degree,
didn't use it.
Okay,
fine,
but you spent all this money to go to
that school and should it have cost that
much money?
Should,
should the rates on loans be with you?
I don't think so.
I think that's,
that's a real scam.
You,
you know,
you didn't probably understand or we're
ill equipped to understand like all of
us were when it came to school.
Yeah.
When you're 18,
you don't know what the fuck do.
I mean we didn't really understand how,
what a racket it was at the time.
So I,
you know,
I totally feel for her there.
And then,
so then she goes,
she gets a different job doing something
else but made her great money but she
hated it.
Didn't like it.
What didn't want to be in that.
All right.
So then chose to fight and do like,
you know,
personal trainers stuff and then would
always gripe about how she didn't make
enough money and it's like,
well,
you could do,
okay,
well then how about this,
you,
you charge x amount per hour normally.
Well,
how about you set a limit to where you
get to x amount of people and then once
you go over that,
now you double the,
the fee because it's not really worth it
to you anymore,
is it?
So you create,
uh,
an increase in you,
you see what your,
what your minimum is.
And then over that and if people are
wanting to pay it,
then they pay it.
Why couldn't do that?
That would be,
that would be unethical to charge these
people double what I'm charging these
people or whatever.
It's was like,
well,
okay then how about you create a class
schedule set up and you iron out some
time here and it's very specific here.
Instead of teaching one person,
you teach five people,
but then you charge them,
you know,
two thirds what you charge it.
No,
it's just like,
well I could,
it's like,
well,
okay,
if you,
at the end of the day we have to do what
we need to do to pay our bills and do
these things and do whatever,
but we also have to determine how we
acquire those bills to what our expenses
are going to be.
And if we can't create a system that
supports that,
then we have to reevaluate that and then
change appropriately.
The one thing we can't do is just be
upset,
you know?
And that's what people like to do,
of course,
because they would like it to be,
oh,
I can do this or I can do,
I should be able to do this.
I should be able to do that.
It's like,
well,
nobody can.
You can't do these things.
You can and just chase their tail,
go around in circles.
Freedom,
uh,
being truly free,
and let's just say an existential sense
means that you have to take
responsibility for all these actions,
but it's also all on you to find your
own success.
And that means you're going to fail.
That means you're going to struggle.
That means all these difficult,
you're going to happen.
But I personally believe that through
struggle and these difficulties,
that's where growth comes as well.
Well,
the question is what's the alternative?
The alternatives.
What?
You sit around and complain whenever
someone else's more successful than you
sit around and complain that you're not
making enough money.
You sit around and complain that the
deck deck is stacked against you.
Sit around and complain that you didn't
use your education.
Sit around and complain that in your
field of choice.
And it didn't succeed.
Here's the other thing.
A lot of people then want to find
somebody who is the reason for their
downfall.
This thing is what's keeping me from,
uh,
being successful as the boyfriend.
I wasn't,
you know,
I,
everything I did was to help as much as
I grow.
Too Big,
too much shit,
too opinionated,
too smart and tired.
Um,
yeah,
I,
I put it,
you know,
at the end of the day,
fuck,
I got,
you know,
I got completely betrayed and cheated on
for months in the end of it.
So it's just like,
oh,
well,
you know,
I put all this investment into trying to
help this other person and create a life
with them only to get completely screwed
over in the end.
But I'm sorry day about that.
But we're getting super personal here.
It's true.
But,
but what it comes down to also is that
when you look at these kinds of things,
you have to say,
well,
okay,
well what would I have done differently?
And you should be like,
for the most part,
you shouldn't have done anything
differently.
You know,
when you invest in somebody else,
when you do for somebody else,
you don't do it for the return or for
what you think you're to get out of
them.
You do it because you're doing it
because it,
it is what you believe is the right
thing to do.
And then to be,
you know,
you can be upset about other,
the way things have turned out.
You can be upset about like,
well,
you know,
ethically I think you did this or you
did that and you can be upset about
those things.
But then two,
it's just like whenever you come across
that person that just has nothing but
shitty things to say about their,
like,
it's probably you.
Oh Dude,
you know,
for me,
I could be like,
Nah,
I thought my ex was the greatest woman
I'd ever met.
And she absolutely possessed the
qualities that,
uh,
aligned with that.
But she also had some really terrible
ones that ended up being,
you know,
horrible.
Whenever you meet someone and all they
do is complain about their axes,
it's usually there's a little of them
and what they're saying.
But see that that's just,
you know,
this is just human beings in their own
existence and so be it their
relationship,
be it their business,
be it,
you know,
all these things are,
are all stemming from the same elements
within themselves.
Now they are subject to others,
very specific elements too.
Like things that relationship like what
kind of elements?
Well,
okay.
When it comes to a point to like what's
the,
for most people,
like what's the,
the big factor in not getting their shit
together.
Uh,
the big factor,
not getting their shit together is not
coming to terms with their own
inefficiency,
uh,
failures or inability to accomplish a
certain task and looking outside of that
for a reason versus looking internally
to see like,
I didn't have enough a skill to do x,
y to do this thing or I didn't put in
enough time to acquire the skill to do
that.
Or I made a mistake here that costs this
when it comes to our relationships,
you know,
it's there.
What,
where it lives,
where the difficulty lies.
There can be specific to different
emotional elements,
Dubai,
you know,
versus your work versus,
uh,
how you even find time to make the most
out of your,
your leisure time.
You know,
these are the,
every,
every situation has its own subjectivity
to it based on these other external
factors that change from each situation.
But ultimately everything stemming from
you anyways.
So your way of approaching these things
and dealing with these problems and how
you let them affect you.
And I'm not just talking about being a
complete stoic and being just cold and
unfeeling,
unaffected and I'm feeling,
it's just about having these things
happen.
And then what do you do about it?
You know,
how do you also,
how do you measure that metric?
If you have the greatest year of life
and then you have,
you know,
an hour that's super shitty in traffic,
did that become,
and that really stuck with you and
someone hit your car and your,
you know,
my challenge has got a dent in it and
it's like,
ah,
did I really have the worst day ever or
did I just have an hour of an
aggravation that sucked.
But ultimately how can that,
if I allow that to take away from
everything that happened up to that
point,
then,
you know,
I just assigned all this value into this
one moment that really it was
unnecessary trained.
A lot of fighters you work.
Do you,
do you sit down and talk to them about
this kind of shit as well?
100% is this a big part of like how you
like think about it as a program for
sure.
Because whoever I take under my wing,
I don't just train people to train them.
Um,
I don't eat them.
Being fighters is one piece of their
life.
One element once,
honestly,
eventually it'll be,
it'll be a small element,
but it,
but it has a lot of impact and meaning I
mentor people when I work with them.
I'm trying to help them visualize and
achieve their greatest state of being
from what they can get.
Now,
fighting may be a vehicle to help try to
achieve that,
but ultimately they're living their life
and they have a,
they have something that they're trying
to accomplish with that.
And so for me,
I'm trying to help them realize what
that is and that's going to be different
from other,
for other people.
Just as much as you can't coach everyone
the same way.
Everybody needs something a little
different in terms of what they're
trying to achieve.
And people want to achieve different
things.
Of course,
they've got this,
they have this element of fighting and
success within fighting that that is a
bond that is a similarity amongst the
rest of them and even amongst me.
But beyond that,
that changes from there on out.
So,
um,
you know,
just recently I've been working with
Travis Browne,
Eh,
you know,
people are like,
Holy Fuck,
you guys are your homeys what the hell
happened?
And it's just,
there's,
the thing was,
is that Travis,
uh,
was,
had tried to get in touch with me
through a marina before,
like,
hey,
he really liked,
he really,
really wants to talk to you.
And I'm just like,
ah,
okay.
I want what he wants to talk about.
And this is like,
uh,
over a year ago I think.
And then,
but for one reason,
the other,
we weren't able to ever cross paths,
but through that time it would keep
coming back.
He really wants to,
he really liked,
he really liked to really liked to see
you,
not just text you,
not just chat with you on the phone but
actually see you.
Okay.
You know,
that already says something to me that
that already has a lot more meaning.
And so sure enough,
I meet up with them this,
this one time with a coffee shop and he
just wanted to sit down,
man to man I and just go over like any
of the beef that we had had and,
and make his statements any apologies
and,
and anything that I might have to say in
any apologies.
And I was like,
Holy Fuck,
you know,
a man,
uh,
I use man,
I'm not trying to be specific,
but any person that is willing to sit
down and be accountable and hear
somebody else's side and just show up
and be like,
look man,
I'm not looking for something from you,
but I'm trying to be open and deal with
whatever this,
this is out here.
Put it to bed.
Yeah,
that's very admirable.
Exactly.
It is such a rare commodity.
And how long ago did this happen?
Uh,
maybe about six months ago.
And he's got a fight schedule runs,
right?
Well maybe he's even a little more than
six months ago.
He's fighting a Alex Olynyk.
And so he hits me up,
he goes,
Hey,
I would love it if you could help me
out.
So for me it was a no brainer.
Like fuck yeah,
I'll be there.
All right.
So I drove out to vegas with one of my
guys show,
Hey Yamamoto who was getting ready for
his,
uh,
the kill chain kid is fighting a locally
here in cxf.
So I'm like,
I'm going to finish his kid's camp out
here,
away from everybody else and I'm going
to help you out at the same time.
Cool.
So he put us up in his place.
Uh,
we would go and we train twice a day.
I would work with him on grappling.
I would spar with him and,
you know,
just take on that role of coach
alongside Ricky Lundell and Ray sefo and
he's a fantastic student.
When did you start working with ray?
Uh,
I think he's been working for,
with ray for about a year now.
About a year.
I think that's a good mood.
He's kicking again.
Thank you.
On knees,
which is great.
Yeah.
Guy Six foot seven.
He's six [inaudible] seven and moves
like,
yeah.
How many crews and when he was not,
sorry dominic.
But I mean,
when he was at his best for a
heavyweight,
there's no one who moves like him.
He was,
he's very agile on his feet.
He's got great,
great quickness,
good a and he's got great reach,
good power.
Uh,
hell I should know.
And,
uh,
the thing is,
he,
he was having,
he just didn't feel that he was getting
what he best needed.
So he made a change.
And even still for fighting someone like
Alexi,
he felt that,
oh,
we'll having a guy that was a good
grappler and also good at that head and
arm position,
which Alexi likes,
um,
to have someone come in here and work
with him in these very specific areas.
But,
you know,
for me it's like,
well,
if you want me to be here,
I'll be here and I'll help you in any
way I can.
And so,
uh,
I would work with them while we're spar
and we would do situational stuff.
And,
uh,
you know,
he was just like a sponge and watching
him get better every day and having some
other,
uh,
guys around to help and be bodies too,
and ended up being great.
It also is great for show,
hey,
because I was able to,
uh,
put him in a very isolated environment
and keep his focus,
so razor sharp.
And he went and knocked this guy out in
22 seconds who was undefeated.
That's awesome.
So,
uh,
so now it's,
you know,
travis is in town doing some press stuff
and I'm going to try and link up with
him as much as possible and just keep
working with them.
And the thing is,
he's the guys like that.
I mean,
they're already physical.
They already have fights under their
belt.
They already accomplished it with them.
It's about nuance.
So you're going to be like,
as head coach,
uh,
there's discussion of that.
Yeah,
maybe just,
I mean,
but the reality is,
is that I,
I just need to do whatever it is I can
do to help him and his team and be a
part of all that.
And you know,
whether I'm a head coach or assistant
coach or I don't,
I don't really care.
It doesn't matter what the title is,
just you need to be in there in the
trenches with these guys putting our
heads together and helping travis be the
best he can be as as a fighter and end
even.
Then while through these training
sessions,
you know,
teaching somebody about getting out of a
move or teaching somebody about doing a
move,
but wrapped in that whole bubble is,
okay,
you're having a hard time right now.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
That's okay because you're still moving
forward.
Don't worry about how difficult it is.
Sometimes this is going to be hard as
shit.
Other times things will work just like
that.
It doesn't matter.
The matter is you got to keep going.
You've got to keep moving forward.
You got to keep fighting and you got to
keep working and you then went,
you know,
from,
from one position it's like,
well,
you can't afford to be here at all.
So no matter how hard it is,
you got to get out,
but you can rest over here.
Or it's like a,
you know,
this,
this training session was super fucking
hard.
That's great.
If you're not pushing yourself into your
absolute exhaustion now,
how do you think you're going to perform
when it's at its utmost?
So it wasn't getting that?
No,
no,
no.
I think it's just,
I'm just throwing out examples,
but I still about working with him on a
mental level too,
and getting his mind and that best state
to then best use those physical
capabilities because ultimately,
in my opinion,
mental is the most important aspect when
it comes to fighting.
How you approach this things,
your mentality towards each individual
skirmish within that,
that fight that eventually leads to
either your success or your failure and
um,
that is always,
that's always the thing.
It's like whether I could teach somebody
to throw a kick this way or kicked that
way or you know,
there's always a way to make something
work.
You know?
Maybe there are some techniques that are
more low percentage than others
especially,
but there'll always be a guy that can
make it work.
You know?
However,
your mental,
the way you approach a fight mentally is
the thing
fucking thing.
That is the hardest thing to hone.
The hardest thing just to change over
the hardest realizations to create is
all in terms of how you mentally
approach a fight,
how to control your nerves or how to
over fighting this out like as a book.
Yeah,
I do.
I think about writing.
I think in terms of fighting,
I think about writing in terms of
philosophy.
I think about maybe doing speaking
engagements,
stuff like that.
You know,
talk to me about a few sat down and came
up with like sort of a comprehensive
step by step for,
for young fighters they'll be like super
valuable maybe,
I don't know.
I guess if you,
if you come up,
sure you could do that and uh,
which of course is going to be just like
you said,
framework.
Yeah.
Give them tools to fall back on.
If they're in a certain situation,
this is something you can call on.
This is something you can think about if
you find yourself stuck.
This is the mindset instead of just
swimming out there freaking out and
treading water and trying to figure out
how long you do it for,
have a very specific mindset that you
adopt or that you take on when you're in
a bad spot.
Sure.
And,
and a lot of,
uh,
drills and things that I'll create for,
for fighters are based on creating
comfort and,
and
charity to where things get to a point
where you're not thinking about it
anymore,
but you're,
you're so comfortable and in that
moment,
in that space that you can react and act
easily the most easily as possible.
And also once you end up in a position
that is even,
that is a negative to you,
that is a detrimental how to then work
your way through it.
And still do.
So with comfort,
like I loved watching Liz Carmouche and
Ronda is back because Rhonda states so,
so calm that that's how she was able to
work her way through it.
Fight that arm off her head,
keep in good position,
and eventually work our way out of it
instead of seizing up and possibly,
you know,
locking in place.
And then Liz being able to finish that
face locker,
that show,
what did you think about that?
Kevin leak.
He has a fight.
I didn't watch it.
Watch.
He didn't watch it.
No.
How dare you?
I,
I know I'm a fighter that doesn't really
watch fights is a crazy ending.
So I heard,
yeah,
Kevin Lee took ts as back,
which is CASS's thing,
right?
Yeah.
And he took his back,
sunk the choke in guess afar off.
He went palm to palm key asks,
uh,
like it was trying to gut it out.
He says,
and Mario Yamasaki steps in,
it stops it before he taps.
I wouldn't have done that.
No one does that.
Especially do it choke.
It's one thing if a guy's arm is snapped
and you see it broken and then you call
the fight.
Right.
But this is not that.
This is,
and he's saying that he thought he went
out.
It's just a hundred percent poor
officiating.
I mean,
I haven't seen any argument from anybody
on the right side.
I mean,
on,
in terms of,
um,
people that are either work for the UFC,
trainers,
fighters,
even Jujitsu athletes.
Yeah.
Everybody says,
but I don't go out.
You gotta let them go out.
It's not great.
It's not a bad thing.
But,
uh,
you know,
people don't know.
It's not,
you don't get,
it's not like getting knocked out.
Yeah.
He could have been shut off being with
two chicks.
Yeah.
It doesn't,
it doesn't hurt you as my point for
people who don't understand what we're
advocating.
It's not like let a guy get knocked out
what we'd get knocked out.
It's not good the way you get choked
out.
It's almost nothing.
It literally is almost nothing.
Pretty much.
It's,
it's,
you're,
you're next going to be sore.
Yeah,
for sure.
I don't think,
uh,
yeah,
I know Mario.
I've known him for a long time and uh,
he's made a mistake.
And that's the thing,
you referees are human.
They all looked,
it's a fucking very hard job.
He probably thought castle went out.
He thought he saw here we can get,
take a look at it here.
Let's let play the whole thing back from
the beginning,
Jamie.
So you could see that.
I can only get it.
Okay.
Just,
okay.
Go from there.
So He's get it.
He locks it on the next year.
He's got the plastic trying to kiss his
fighting.
He peels it off.
And then Kevin Luxy Body Tried d trial
triangle down tighter.
I see it.
Yeah.
Gets that palm to palm and look at this.
See,
he's fighting it off and look,
he's not out at all.
He's like,
I didn't tap.
What the fuck I didn't tap.
I think that's a bullshit stoppage.
And it's not,
you know,
look,
Mario made a mistake,
but it's a bullshit stoppage.
100%.
I can't even imagine anybody defending
that stoppage.
No reason.
Well sound like,
because if you don't defend your that
making that stoppage,
he's crazy.
Well,
I understand that but,
but people don't want to,
uh,
they didn't want it to end.
They don't want to accept any blame.
Blame May,
he's in,
he's gutting it out.
Yeah.
He's,
he's gutting it out,
man.
They look,
people don't realize it takes a lot of
effort to squeeze that palm to palm in
particular using a lot of muscle.
There's not a whole lot.
It's not the same kind of leverage that
you get when you do the,
she,
I see his hands Kinda,
you know,
around the area.
But I mean you can still grab,
you could touch the guy's arm.
Yeah.
And they're,
they're stiff.
Yeah.
He's still resisting and you don't have
to,
it's not like strikes where you have to
have your hands up covering yourself,
like to resist it.
He can resist by just really flexing his
neck.
It's not smart.
And tyron Woodley had the best
commentary on this,
honestly.
He was on that a UFC panel show and he's
like,
look,
you shouldn't,
he goes,
you shouldn't be in that position in the
first place.
You shouldn't be defending it like that
with your hands like that.
And you shouldn't have let that guy get
his arm under your Chin like that.
All of those things are bad technique
and he's dead.
Right?
Yeah,
he's dead right.
The whole thing is kind of crazy.
I mean,
yeah,
but he took him,
he took a beating before that.
This is one of the things you don't get
in the context of this.
I think he was getting shellacked yes,
cause Kevin Lee had his back and while
he had his back,
see if you can find that.
Well,
I mean I can see that he's cut.
Oh he's been bleeding.
He had his back and he was beating the
fuck out of him from behind with his
back.
Just Bang,
Bang,
Bang.
While he's back riding them.
He'd beat the shit out of him before
that.
So He's probably stunned.
Right.
I'm also of the of the sort that sees
guys that are getting hit and the four
point position turtle position,
you know guys are swinging on him and
they've got their arms up in their
covered like often.
A lot of times they're like,
just keep letting it go.
I you're not,
you're not getting through.
But reps will see like,
oh,
it looks bad when we're stopping.
It's like,
but he's not really getting hit.
I agree with you 100% I think there's
been many fights.
Were fights were stopped quick when a
guy was covered up,
but there's nothing else he could do
cover up.
What else is he going to do?
Yeah,
the guy swinging on him,
but he can't,
can't land a successful,
the only reason that guys flooring so
hard really.
I mean,
well not the only,
but the main reason is probably because
he thinks the ref's gonna stop it
exactly on that.
He wouldn't put that kind of effort into
it unless he's just completely losing
his shit.
Me and like,
Oh fuck it change and he's not thinking
about it.
Which could come back to haunt him.
Like I've seen a lot of times.
Yeah.
Old,
old,
old
cool fights guys even in mount,
just try on load on a guy and the guy
survives.
It reverses it and eventually he gets
his
and it and it's done.
You know,
we got a car when Brock Lesnar.
Yeah.
Perfect example.
Shane Carwyn beat the fucking shit out
of Brock Lesnar for a full round.
Got on top of them.
Full mouth dropping bombs on them.
Somehow or another,
brock lesnar's survives.
Take Shane down the sac around,
submit some quick.
Yup.
It happens.
You got to let fights play out.
But I think in that situation it's,
he,
there's no for stopping
the fight because it's not like strikes
like w there could be an argument where
brock lesner is on the bottom and he's
not moving enough and maybe some people
are a little bit more cautious,
might have stopped that fight.
But there's no argument to stop that.
I don't think that the fight should have
been stopped.
Uh,
yes and easy to do a better job of not
letting guys get under his chin.
Yeah.
What do you,
what do you do about that?
You're the commissioner.
If you're the king of the world,
do you do a contact contact
commissioner?
You,
uh,
I dunno.
I kind of feel like you have to keep
him,
give him the win.
It's hard to reverse it like that.
It's a mistake that the referee fucked
up for sure.
He stopped the fight,
but he stopped the fight based on a,
and this is where I want to go against
myself.
A very advantageous position that was as
close to finalizing and finishing as you
can discern where a guy's no longer
defending with his hands.
He's hanging in there.
I mean,
I think Mario fucked up cause he didn't
let it get to 10,
but he let it get to nine.
It got denied.
Yeah.
That's the thing too.
He was so locked into that show.
Can't take his victory away.
I feel like you can't take Kevin these
victory away.
Me Too.
Uh,
it's just no good.
They're no good that comes up that it's
not good,
but you give them an immediate rematch.
I think that's the move.
That's exciting.
That's a good,
yeah,
I could see that.
But here's the thing,
you know,
this is price fighting,
right?
Is there the interest all right there.
Make it happen.
I think through it and make it happen.
Because you're going to mention the
promoter's got to make money on it.
Yeah.
I think that's a good fight to have in
Detroit because I think they're going to
do a UFC in Detroit.
I heard I'm scheduled to do as a UFC.
Isn't Detroit having a UFC basically
every night?
Oh No.
I think it's different.
It's like a,
it's more like a battle cade old school
chunk already just hanging around with
me.
Like,
oh,
that's so sexy.
Sexy to,
he's riding him like a pony.
Most people have no idea.
Oh,
I,
I have party with John Perretti.
That is,
I love John Proteins commentary.
Oh,
it's hell.
It's,
I just enjoy him.
He's fantastic.
I mean,
and you know him,
he brought a lot of a really good
fighters to the world of him.
And then he had a great eye for picking
talent.
He was the guy that find,
found Andre Arlovski.
He,
uh,
yours in Novia,
Mario Sperry.
Mari Smith.
Matt Hume.
Yeah.
Well,
I was going to bring it up.
Sakuraba like when soccer rob a fought
Conan and the UFC,
that was the first time we saw Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu black belt gets submitted.
Right.
We were like,
whoa.
We thought they were in vulnerable.
Well,
and up to that and the fight before
that,
uh,
he clips soccer up with a good shot.
Sakharova drops in on a single and then
big John Accidentally stop the fight,
but then they let him fight again,
which is the craziest fucking thing
ever.
Like they would never do that.
Never.
That's crazy.
I forgot about that.
That is a very,
very,
very nice randy couture beat Marie Smith
for the UFC heavyweight title and his,
his tights got torn so you could see
his,
his speedos underneath that that randy
was wearing.
And so when frank shamrock also beat
Kevin Jackson.
Yup.
Armbar oh,
it's been like 20 seconds.
Which shoes on?
Yup.
Yeah.
Old School,
man.
I loved it.
That was the first year.
That's when I quit.
I quit that UFC.
I'm like,
I'm not going to Japan.
That's when I quit the back in the old
days when I was doing the post fight
interviews.
Did we do on a back in the day on the
uh,
on like the graffiti brick wall?
Yeah,
we did something man.
Yeah.
That was,
um,
you know what,
when you won the title,
I was there but I wasn't working for the
UFC.
I was just watching and uh,
that was back when I was just a friends
with Dana and I was uh,
I was just going to the events and
enjoying them.
I remember watched you fight randy from
like,
I think I was like six feet away.
I think it was like front row back in
the day.
Josh Barnett back in the fucking baby
face assassin with less stars and a lot
less gray hair.
Dude.
I remember you fighting in Hawaii.
Yup.
Super Brawl.
Yeah.
Dan Severn and that eight man tournament
that I won that had all those dudes in
Abu Dhabi champion Rigo Rodriguez and
uh,
John Marsh.
Uh,
Travis Fulton.
I think you only had like 115 fights at
that point.
How much does travis have now?
It doesn't have like 305 snowing now.
Something insane.
Jeremy Horn.
I always thought it was insane because
he had like one 50 and then you find out
about travis and everyone's got like a
hundred does he?
Yeah,
I got a hundred victories,
I don't think.
Sorry.
You said you've been doing a little bit
of pro wrestling but no fighting.
He had a very gray blurry line between
fighting pro wrestling to put it
charitably.
There was like some,
some,
there was a couple that people had
called it into question.
A couple of the Katas in there.
Mm.
Yeah.
Well it's amazing that he kept it up as
long as he did,
but that was because of a solid
wrestling,
you know?
Well that just like real serious
competitor,
you know,
he had that competition streak that
would allow him to continue to drive
and,
and perform like that.
But as he got older,
you know the wrong match ups.
It could be a guy who never even heard
of and it's like,
oh shit.
Dance ever just got shellacked.
Yeah.
Well,
when you look back at your initial
fights in mma,
like in super broad and then entering
into the UFC,
which is like,
when was your first fight in the UFC?
What year?
Uh,
2001 yeah.
See,
that was when I was 2000 not working
with them yet.
That was when I was UFC 28 yeah.
Gam Mcgee and then UFC [inaudible] was
Pedro Hazel 32 Assam Schilt 34 was Bobby
Hoffman 30 slot.
Pedro his or when Pedro his,
it was Pedro.
His,
oh yeah dude.
We showed a clip yesterday of Pedro,
his own leg kicking some guy and making
them fly through the air.
Some journalists holds the pad on his
leg and Pedro leg kicks him in.
The guy's legs literally go upside down
where his legs are above his head.
He goes flying.
He's such a cool dude,
man.
It's just like seeing him over over all
the years.
Training at his gym in,
in Brazil.
When I was down there,
he can't pick me up.
Uh,
picked up me and my accident.
We,
we went out there and train with this
guy,
a master late dial.
Who is one of the,
was this before or after your second
fight?
Uh,
after our second flight.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
we were down there,
me and my ex and uh,
eh,
we're down there to help corner Shana
and her last fight in the UFC,
it was in Brazil against a Nunez.
And while we're down there,
it's like,
Hey,
I,
I still want to get in training.
I don't want to train with all the that
Luke delievery like catch derived guys
that I can.
And so yeah,
what we trained with a master lay towel
for a while and Pedro is let us use his
gym and we would sit there and talk and
I go,
you know,
one of the things about Pedro,
I go,
he,
he taught me how to throw the counter
right hand even better than than I had
ever known.
And that pivot step and they hit it from
the other angle because he knocked me
the fuck out with it and it was so
beautiful and the replay,
like,
I need to learn that.
I got to learn that that's two.
And Pedro would just laugh about it and
he goes,
oh,
well,
you know,
you got me.
I go,
who gives a shit,
man?
We were too busy having fun.
Would you caught him with a left hook?
Right?
Uh,
I caught him with a counter right hand,
did you over his Jab and I saw him
stumble a little bit and I charged for
it.
And then with a running left hook.
Yeah.
Um,
because I saw,
uh,
the window of opportunity to get to get
in there,
I'd already stunned them.
Uh,
and so to a degree I'm like,
thanks Pedro.
Thanks.
[inaudible] the hardest leg kicks you've
ever felt a cro cop,
Cro,
cop.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Well,
I would,
I would imagine,
I mean,
if anybody here,
here's just a cro cop story.
So it's me and Marco and Eric Paulson
and we're training in Vegas.
Uh,
I think,
I don't know if I was doing commentary
on that show.
If I was fighting pebble,
not too low.
Either way.
We're training at this gym in Vegas and
miracle came out.
So we're rolling around and training
together and have a good time.
And,
and I think I was fighting and so on,
uh,
Paulson's holding pads for me and
miracles like,
ah,
do this with your leftover and said,
all right,
how about Nah,
that's not it.
No,
no,
no.
Here,
let me show you here.
You hold the pads.
So Paulson's got this full on typepad
leather typepad and he's holding it for
miracles,
right hook.
Since you know,
we're talking lead Hook essentially,
right?
So miracle was like,
no,
I want you to do this.
You know,
you're doing it like x is,
I need you to do it like this.
So Watch,
oh,
and he hits this heat,
right?
Hooks,
this pad,
this typepad it goes,
it tears the straps off of Paulson's arm
and it goes flying across the room and
hits the wall and bounces off the wall
and falls on the fucking ground.
And everyone was just like,
uhhh.
And Paulson is just,
his hand is still like this and he looks
at me and he looks at a miracle and
miracles and,
and I just,
everybody's just,
it's just silence.
Wham flat.
But I am,
I just went,
see,
I took that,
that that's what I was getting hit with
and I still managed to stay on my feet
because I'm an idiot.
Yeah.
Geez.
I remember thinking,
how the fuck is this guy?
He's just at his best is just absolute
pure like explosive power.
Just just destruction.
Yeah.
Well,
you know Bob Saps eyeball and he did one
fight.
Remember that?
Yeah.
Dude,
he crushed people with,
with those high kicks.
He,
his middle kick was so dangerous to me
is middle and is locate where the most
dangerous because I felt like you could,
you could,
you could see,
you could more read the high kick,
but if you read the high kick or if you
were to two d to set up to defend the
high kick,
if he ripped you in your body,
that's your ribs.
Can we chop that shag heath herring
versus cro?
Cop were cro cop's kicking them in the
body and cro,
cop's Shin is like halfway to his spine.
I think he was only one kick to one kick
and it was like boom.
But it's when you see the penetration of
that kick,
you realize like that's insane.
And he had a taekwondo background that
helped him to be,
but you know,
a guy like that you could have gave him
fucking,
you could have had him doing anything
and he's just going to be a beast.
You know,
he had just such ferocious,
ferocious explosive power.
I remember his stare down with vandelay
probably the best deer down of all time.
First Time vandelay got out,
stared.
No,
he's vandelays like doing the crazy eyes
and Mirko was just staring at him like a
fucking evil predator.
The two of them looking at each other.
I'm like,
I got to give that one to cro cop.
I can't believe this.
Well,
think about cro,
cop,
Cro,
cop that got that motherfucker was,
yeah,
look at that kick.
Oh Fuck Jesus Christ.
I mean that is deep into his body and
right,
right where his liver is.
That's a insane power kick.
That's that left leg.
Yup.
And he was the first one to flatline
vandelay to remember that when the head
kicked vandelay because uh,
I was,
I was watching that fight because my
next,
cause I was going to go fight Nogueira
after that.
So I'm sitting here hoping that these
guys beat the shit out of each other and
he goes out there and just fucking
crushes them.
So now I'm just sitting here thinking,
God dammit,
that dude spent two minutes of beating
the hell out of this guy and now I gotta
go out and fight.
Nogueira how crazy is the chin on Mark
Hunt?
He gets fucking head kicked.
Fullon he goes down and gets right back
up.
Oh,
there's an Ovi but here's the vandelay
one.
Climbing a ridiculous speed and power.
And because of the fact that he had that
traditional martial arts background,
he didn't step before he threw that
kick.
A lot of times he just threw it and you
didn't see it coming.
That one just goes over the top of the
glove and that's right leg.
Yeah,
that's right.
Leg Hospital.
Left leg.
Cemetery.
Body.
Yeah.
Done Dude.
Now that fight,
I remember he hit Mark Hunt with that a
couple times.
Yeah.
He just,
well he dropped him with it.
And one of the fights and k one k one
fight.
Not In the,
and the MMA fight.
Mark Hunt actually one that one.
Yeah.
Well that was my editorial to it on the
chin.
That doesn't a Guy Carwyn.
No,
wait,
that's a raw waterman.
Ron Waterman.
There you go.
Boink Minataro was one of those guys.
It was almost like too tough for his own
good when he was younger.
Well that's why who acts kick.
That's why when he got towards the end
of his career,
he was just getting knocked out left and
right because he'd taken,
he had lived on his chin for so long
that he could no longer take a shot
anymore.
And that's honestly,
it's not that uncommon.
Uh,
Ooh.
Fujita getting a need,
uh,
as he got a cooler,
easy highlight reel that you forget
sometimes how insane the highlight reel
of Mirko Cro cop is.
Well,
people in the,
oh Alexander in the UFC never really
saw,
they didn't see this guy,
you know what I mean?
No,
he was in pride.
Well,
I still maintain to this day that like
pride was some of the most exciting and
spectacular fights in the early days of
MMA by far.
They agree I'm insane.
Matchups and especially because it was a
big percentage of it was the heavyweight
division was a huge percentage of what
they,
and,
and the stage that they set for us to
compete on wasn't crabs and people's
like talent super arena.
It was fighting in front of,
I mean,
I was fighting in front of Pete like
40,000 people every time I went out
there swishing,
it could've maintained.
I was a fan of it.
When,
when I was even working for the UFC,
I was always a big pride fan.
I'm like,
look,
there's room for everybody.
Of course,
you know,
and the thing is the people that were by
having pride,
it opened up eyes.
I would always say like having another
company with a different flavor.
Maybe it will draw in other,
other,
uh,
fans that wouldn't maybe necessarily be
a fan of the UFC,
but they liked the way that pride did
it.
And so that would get them interested in
mma and therefore then they might also,
okay,
well maybe I will give this ufc stuff
with tribe.
Maybe.
Well,
I like this one fighter.
Uh,
so I'll watch when he's on,
you know,
it just,
it expands the market.
It doesn't diminish it.
I think that's the same thing with bell
tour.
Yeah,
I really do.
I mean,
I think that what,
what's good about Bella tours that
they're developing real world class
talent now,
Michael Chandler,
you know,
Michael Venom page now rory is over
there.
I mean there's world class talent there.
It's true.
And uh,
you know,
he had mitre on fight fueled our,
which you crazy man.
You know,
double knockdown gets up first and it's
crazy.
Crazy thing you can't,
can't plan for.
So a guy like fate or when you see him
at this stage of his life and you see
him getting code again,
what,
what are your thoughts on that when you
watch that?
It sucks to see that that's the case.
I mean,
I love Matt known to man.
He's a,
he's a great dude.
I,
I trained him when I can and I'm glad to
see him get that victory.
It's a massive victory fund as was I,
but I'm a,
I'm a friend and I had been a friend of
orders for such a long time.
It's,
it's,
it sucks to see him not doing well even
saying his name right.
It's a big commitment.
Yeah.
It's like everybody else's fader.
But y'all got to get,
you got your fancy Yannis,
right?
Like Dostoyevsky Fyodor Dostoyevsky not
fate or,
well,
what does everybody say instead of dose,
gift,
Ski?
I think they just don't say anything.
They're like the d a f d what's the
correct pronunciation?
Dus Dose.
[inaudible] Dostoyevsky Dostoyevsky
Dostoyevsky isn't a weird hub.
Languages like develop,
like they're totally different kinds of
sounds like,
you know,
English has certain sounds.
Sure.
Russian has these like very specific
noises that you have to,
and then you go to like tonal languages,
Thai or Vietnamese.
Oh,
man.
Or Chinese.
Oh,
yeah.
Crazy.
So interesting.
You know,
and,
um,
uh,
Steve Rinella again was here and he had
been in Guyana and they had these
interviews they did with these local
people that were speaking in their
native tongue.
And it's like this really strange
ancient language.
It doesn't sound like anything else.
It's a really cool to hear.
It's like,
wow,
you,
this might be like what mayans sounded
like.
Ha.
Yeah.
Really freaky.
Well,
when I was at
Romania,
they were some,
some of the,
I don't,
I don't know the truth on this stuff.
Uh,
I haven't done the research,
so it up to your listeners to go follow
up that they were saying,
the Romanians has said that they have
found texts and,
and,
and archeological findings that would
show a language that was not a romance
language that still possessed words that
existed in modern day Romanian.
And that the idea that perhaps that the
Romanian language was older than Latin.
Oh.
So,
but they also had a,
the also went to the,
uh,
the palace of live the impaler and in
the middle of Bucharest,
which was awesome.
Oh Wow.
You got to see that guy's house.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's all dug underground,
uncertain.
And so that,
you know,
keep it cool
for people who've lad the impaler was,
he was a guy who literally put,
put people on sticks and then eat in
front of them.
He would stick sticks through their
assholes and I put them on spikes out
their mouth and then have them all lined
up around him while he sat down and ate.
He also took the,
uh,
the merchants or the,
the,
these guys that he felt had been,
uh,
he's cheating and scamming the we'll Aki
in the,
in the area that he was in in Romania
will lock you.
They're the people and really getting
super rich off their backs in a way that
they didn't have an option.
And so he went and grabbed them,
them in their kid,
their kids are and would have them
build.
They were building the steps,
uh,
up to this,
to the,
to his,
to this castle or whatever.
And if,
if the,
if the dad died,
they would just take the kid and put
them in its place.
And it's like,
this is going to get until this is
completely done.
You know your debt still exists.
Whoa.
Jesus Christ.
Brutal Dude.
Brutal Times.
That's the guy that Mary Shelley bitten
all that.
Mary Shelley's Frankenstein.
Mary Frankenstein,
but
they fuck's his name.
He wrote Brahm Stoker.
Bram stoker.
Yeah.
He kind of based it.
A lot of it.
Yeah.
Well,
and also like the story go away,
which is a undead creature in,
in Romania,
which is actually a really pretty funny
Romania movie called sort of toy,
which is like a,
it's a comedy horror thing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's the name they use in that TV show
to the strain.
Oh really?
Yeah.
They use that term a lot.
Have you seen that movie,
that show?
No,
I,
I don't have cable or anything like
that.
I packed since I moved out.
I haven't into my own place.
I hadn't had time to really set up my tv
and all that kind of shit.
So you just live in like a wild person
kind of.
Yeah.
He got an email though,
right?
I have email,
I have internet,
I have my laptop.
So I'm,
I'm do watch netflix like on the laptop,
still watched like documentaries or
something.
I don't,
you don't,
cause I'm,
I'm,
I'm always out and about.
I just got back from Seattle.
Uh,
I was in Vegas Helping Travis and with
my fighter show.
Hey.
Uh,
then I had to go to the fights for my
guys show.
Hey,
an aga,
they both fall on that night and corner
them.
Um,
shit,
when I was,
I went to Japan and pro wrestled in
June,
but I was also there again in March.
Uh,
she,
just a rambling man.
Basically after the dissolution of all
that I had been putting all my efforts
into for four years,
we got past that.
Right.
We moved,
but this was,
this was the very therapeutic,
well,
here's the thing,
it's just like,
all right.
Uh,
no matter what,
you know,
I still have a lot anymore,
but we're not,
we're not,
we're just saying that,
that,
you know,
it's just like a moving into,
I had all these things that I was trying
to accomplish and so it's just like,
all right,
well,
uh,
since I'm not putting energies in these
areas,
then I'm going to take that energy and
put it somewhere else.
I'm going to make,
make use of it.
You know,
don't sell,
pressed and sit around and get bummed
out at life.
No.
Well,
and your own advice,
there's lots of shit to get bummed out
about.
Not even be beyond even that thing that
we're not talking about your podcast,
I wish would happen.
Uh,
I hate to say it,
but Fox really dropped the ball big time
on it and the people that were working
on the podcast,
uh,
just completely shit the bed to the
point of like,
I had,
uh,
had Natto and Scotty Epstein on and
we're sitting there 15 minutes before
we're going to go on and just chatting,
whatever.
And then it's like,
all right guys,
we're going to go,
we're going to fill now.
All right,
three,
two,
all right.
Boom.
Do our thing.
Nobody even pays attention to look at
the front of the footage and cut it from
what's not supposed to be aired.
And then they just throw it up there.
Raw Silver Song and I'd throw was being
[inaudible] and we're all doing our
stuff.
And then I get this email and was like,
Yo,
what the fuck dude?
You know,
I'm,
I do a character and they go,
what are you talking about?
I go look at it and edit it,
edit it all.
And there were stuff like,
uh,
hey,
I know you're going to be on vacation,
but I'm going to do a on location
interview with this bank.
Odour I'm going to get it all.
I'll get all the NP,
I'll just send it to you.
You can cause someone edit it.
Oh,
I'm off on vacation.
I can't help put their fucking nobody
there.
There's zero,
there's no one.
So then I had to go and reach out to
another friend and be like,
hey man,
do you have some time to fucking chop
this up for me?
And just make a few edits.
Yay.
I could do that.
And then put that up.
And then it was another thing like,
okay,
well hey guys,
if I'm going to do this podcast,
I want to have music in it.
I want to have bands that I know and
love and whatever I want to play there
who have rights for their music.
That's a nightmare.
Right.
Well,
so I said,
do you have some legal forms that we can
put together,
some boiler plates that we can do and
have this happen?
Oh,
we don't need it.
You don't need that,
it's just no big deal.
Okay.
So I go and I get the management
artists,
everybody's on
or is this person that said that this is
okay.
Is this guy a young guy that worked
there,
there was the not knowing anything.
Was it like a tech guy?
I am not going to throw anybody's names.
There were these two dudes,
there was one guy that was like,
uh,
he was a part of the head of the
division or whatever.
And then there was another dude,
it was a producer of sorts who I got
along with.
Great.
But when it came to getting it all done,
obviously fucking it did work.
But the guy that was above him was
unable to take blame for anything and
uh,
and own up to any like fuck ups.
And so it wasn't like I was asking for
much from them.
I'm just like,
well,
tell me what we're dealing with here so
I can know how to appropriately act.
And then,
you know,
getting this,
this whole okay about music's all right.
So I go and I do all the legwork,
get everybody to agree.
Have my guest on,
we play some music to start it off.
We played music,
you know,
while they're there while he's there and
I'm being an asshole Masha and around
the room having fun and joking around.
And then I watched the video of it and
it's like silence the fuck I look,
I'm just stomping around the room to
silence.
What the Hell is going on?
Oh yeah.
Illegal wouldn't clear the music and
like well why the fuck are we dealing
with this now?
When I asked you before we even did
podcasts one before we ended the first
episode,
why did we not get that out of the way?
Cause you told me we didn't need it and
it's just like shit like that.
And so we're,
we're,
we're now like,
look,
we're not even doing it for money right
now.
We're just doing it to,
to,
to establish a relationship.
And this already gone sour.
Stop you.
Why do you,
why are you doing it with a person like
a network?
Why do you doing with Fox?
Because they came to me,
you can do it on your own.
They came to me.
Listen,
all you need is that phone right there
and a fucking a microphone that plugs
into it.
It's like I use this one for a podcast
that I did recently.
This is not an endorsement.
I'm just,
uh,
anybody who's listening to this,
it's simple.
This microphone right here,
no endorsement and I have to say the
name of it,
but okay.
It's a blue right.
Okay.
This microphone works on a cord
that plugs directly into your phone.
You set that bitch up like that.
He stick this in.
Bang.
Stick that in your phone.
Press record.
It's that simple.
And I've done actual podcast that
millions of people listened to with this
thing that sits in my hand.
I closed that bitch up like that.
Put it back in this little bag,
stick it in my laptop,
could take it anywhere you go.
It's,
it works on USB.
It takes no energy.
Super easy to do.
And then you just have to upload that
somewhere and you could add,
you could figure out how to edit.
Simple stuff like that.
Audio.
Sure.
You're not talking about like making
records.
You talked about anything,
a simple audio file,
you can figure out how to do that.
And I hear you there.
I also realized that,
uh,
you know,
for me doing a podcast mean it meant it
had to be like the amount of effort I
was going to put into it was going to be
equal to the kind of product I wanted.
So I started,
yeah,
but don't get confused about this,
right?
No,
I hear you there.
You're there.
The effort is in your mind and your
thoughts and what you're trying to put
out there and that's your,
you're really good at that is what I'm
saying,
that you don't need some network.
You just need an account with like
Libsyn or one of these podcasts hosts,
they upload it to itunes.
That's it.
You're done.
You know,
people find out about it.
They like it,
they get addicted to it.
They start download to get more and
more.
You know what I mean?
You're really good at this.
To get connected to something like Fox
and have someone who's non-motivated
they came to me and it sounded like,
all right,
well we could probably monetize this in
some way and exist during the fighter
and the kid days,
uh,
early,
early.
Yeah.
See they thought that they were doing
something and then now they've
completely changed their tune there.
They've decided to,
the only people that they're investing
their time and now are people they have
exclusive relationships with their eye,
their thoughts about the fighter.
And the kid were,
and Brendan shared with me some article
that they were talking about him and
where the fighter and the kid,
they feel like road on the Fox name and
then became really popular and then made
it is a delusional perspective.
I mean,
they don't understand what happened.
What happened is there is an
entertaining show and two guys are
really good.
And then another entertaining show like
mine has them on and then millions of
people find out about it and then they
go on other entertaining shows.
Like whether it is,
uh,
fucking,
Jason Ellis or whether it's whatever
they're doing.
Yeah.
And then this buildup,
the same thing that happened to Tom
Sigora and Christina Palicki and Bert
Kreischer and all these popular
podcasts,
people find out about them and they're
good.
It has nothing to do with Fox zero.
Right.
So he did was host at the end of the day
day.
I mean,
Fox isn't the one creating the content.
Fox is the one that has,
the idea is Fox isn't the one cracking
the jokes,
telling the stories
or it doesn't hurt,
doesn't hurt.
Being connected to foster that,
it's definitely legitimate,
not what they think it is.
And I even said stuff like,
Hey,
I want to have whatever I want on this
podcast.
I have no problem.
I go,
no,
no.
I want to have whatever I want on this
pile.
I want to talk about anything.
No problem.
There's no pussy farts with Josh
Barnett,
Pussy farts with Josh Barnett,
if that's a,
you know where we wanted to go with it.
But of the things I said
to him,
I go,
Hey,
I want to talk about the the the fucking
insane Nazi,
a cult division.
I want to talk about all that crazy shit
that they did and I found this guy who
was an expert and we can talk about all
the weird stuff and cult divisions.
Yeah,
they had an occult division,
the Nazis.
Oh,
okay.
You said it extreme Nazi.
No,
no.
I said the,
the,
the extreme crazy shit of the Nazi.
A cultivation.
How they would go around trying to find
the spear of destiny or the Ark of the
covenant and all these,
right.
I mean,
that's why we have raiders of the lost
Ark and all the really cool movies.
Would you have on to talk about that?
Because I go,
I'm going to bring this guy on to talk
about this stuff and they're like,
can't have Nazis on.
I go,
no,
I'm not.
I'm not talking about Nazis.
I'm not,
this isn't,
he isn't Nazi Holocaust history.
You couldn't have a history professor
maybe wrote a book on Hitler.
Come on and talk about Nazis.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You don't need them.
You don't know what this was.
This was years ago.
And so after that was like all this
stuff was,
was adding up and I'm like,
fuck man,
this sucks.
It's not even their fault,
man.
They're stuck in this old way and they
think this old,
which works for television shows they're
old way works great for television show.
They control the advertising.
They secure the town.
I don't know how much the shows,
it was Fox itself.
I don't know if the machine Fox was
really paying that much attention.
I think it was really just the main dude
who was above who is in charge of this
shit,
who was fucking it up and didn't want to
put the effort in and didn't want to,
you know,
it got to the noise from the last,
the last podcast I did.
Uh,
they didn't even put the video portion
up.
It took them weeks to,
it's just like,
wow.
Okay.
I guess you don't have any contract with
them.
Yeah,
I could.
I could still,
people still hit me up and go,
hey,
we like you.
You know,
we'd love it if you do a podcast again.
I'm just like,
ah,
just do it.
Just do it.
Dude,
you're really good at this.
It's easy,
easy for you.
People can get mad at me.
They're like,
God Damn Joe Rogan,
you always trying to get people to do
podcasts.
I would listen to your podcast if you
had a podcast.
I listened to it all.
I'm saying.
Um,
I,
uh,
I have,
I have lots of things to talk about,
but I do like to talk to a broad variety
of people.
I love the fact that you're bringing on
guys like Jordan Peterson or Sam Harris
or,
uh,
God's sod.
Interesting guys to talk about
interesting stuff.
Even much as possible,
getting the into scraps with crowder
over here,
which I'm like,
oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
I like crowder.
I mean nothing.
I don't know.
I do see him as like an aggregator or
aggravator just kind of like,
like Milo,
like Milo might say something
interesting,
but then he's,
he's couch all of this stuff and trying
to like create shit with people because
part of how they get a lot of attention
and popularity,
but I think he puts out funny stuff too,
man.
He,
he did some funny things where he,
uh,
he's done a bunch of like funny sketches
where he goes undercover as different
people is,
it's like a Communist,
um,
uh,
French character that he goes on the
cover as and no,
no,
no.
Crowder does crowded.
There's a lot of funny shit.
People that get mad at me for saying
he's funny.
I think he's funny.
I think he does funny shit.
He's uh,
he's done some really hilarious social
justice warrior things where he,
uh,
showed up at like some,
well he definitely dressed as a trans
person for a while.
I was trying to like push the boundaries
of what,
what,
like when can you decide that your
transition,
how do you know whether or not someone
has decided that they're transitioning
or whether or not they're hoax and you
know,
like,
who are you to say with that?
I'm not really trans.
Like,
so he went to like one of those a all
women's gyms and said that he was trans
and then they let him in at first and
then after awhile they were like,
what the fuck I'm,
they kicked him out.
I don't think it was an all woman's gym.
In fact,
I think he just went to a gym that said
that they accept trans people and then
when he went in and he wanted to shower
in the women's room,
but he was like,
you know,
I had like a fucking five o'clock
shadow.
Right.
So the idea is like,
it's the sincerity of it is,
is almost what that comes down to.
Like,
well you're not sincere about being
trans.
So is that what it comes?
But he's pointing out like how crazy
these lines are.
Right.
And like where are they?
Whether or not you agree that people
should be able to do whatever they want,
they want to,
which I do.
There is a real hysteria involved in
this and there's something very odd
about these arbitrary lines.
Well,
we decided,
we had a guy that we were watching a
video tape yesterday who identifies as a
six year old girl.
Oh,
the German guy?
No,
he's,
is he German?
He's definitely foreign,
right?
They,
it was all,
yeah,
he had a wife and kids and all that.
And then he's like,
I'm a six year old.
Like what the fuck?
But you have to include that.
So then it's because then it gets to,
well,
can you be transracial can you be like
Rachel Dolezal?
Is that okay?
Can you,
I don't know why not.
Look,
everybody came from Africa originally.
If you identify more with African
Americans than you do,
as I say,
Polish Americans,
why not?
I don't,
well,
Ben Shapiro's argued that that's less
preposterous than changing your gender
and that like why can't you do that?
If you can change your gender?
Like why wait?
He's an interesting one because I like
how hardcore and how like straight to
the point he brings great arguments.
Very smart guy.
I can tell that he's that dude that just
fucking,
he's just,
he doesn't hardly get along with
probably with anyone.
It just got me decided.
Well,
one of those,
one of those personalities,
it's just not good at socializing in any
way.
Like he,
he's very rigid but very smart.
Yeah.
He's,
he,
he seems like a total prick,
but an all right dude.
In his own way,
I guess.
And you know what's funny is it's,
I,
I always,
I'll talk to people about,
you know,
left leftism versus right as I'm,
and I'm like,
well,
you know,
it's pretty easy,
most of the time to look at the right
when they're being idiotic because it's
so preposterous.
Like,
you know,
theologically based arguments or you
know,
if you're going to,
I mean,
that's really what it comes to.
Stuff like that.
Or,
or like,
um,
how they will take this whole stance of
like,
no,
you just,
you get what you can get,
but if you fucking fuck up,
fuck you.
You know,
like the,
these really extreme conservative
arguments usually just are like,
well that's not uncompassionate right?
Yeah,
I know what you know,
it's,
but you go to the left and it's like,
everything is couched in this like,
oh no,
no,
we're,
we're good.
This is all for the good look at how
nice.
Where it being like,
well,
you're just as fascist as this other
guy,
but you,
you couch it into an under a different
thing.
You do things like use postmodernist,
uh,
philosophical arguments to then take the
word racism and redefine it so then it
works for your benefit.
And that not only works against black
people,
it doesn't work against why people like
going against white people.
Yeah.
People get weird with their arguments
and it ultimately becomes a about
control.
Sure.
Of course.
And power is creating power for a
person,
uh,
to,
to affect that against someone else is
in creating or it's also a creating
moral high ground so you can feel as if
you're in the right to say this or that.
And because you are supported by all
these other people around you.
Yeah.
I tried a bow,
I'm trying to balance it out,
I should say,
but people get mad at me when I have too
many right wing people on in a row.
They start thinking like if I've been
accused of being like Fox News,
I'm like,
come on man,
I have left.
He's on all the time.
She's not paying attention.
Whether it's Julie Kedsey or Abby Martin
or a w.
What does it,
Pete Holmes is a super,
super lefty judd apatow.
How's a soup and lefty he was on last
week.
I tried to have as many lefties on as
possible,
but they don't get mad at that.
They only get mad when I have like super
righties on when I have super righties
on.
Then they were like,
oh yo,
your shows like Fox News.
Well,
culturally,
you know,
it's just like,
well we can this,
this,
this argument will listen to you,
but not this one of course.
But at the end of the day,
what really sucks is that when it came
to,
uh,
you know,
in such a,
I had gotten so into a politics because
of my living situation.
I,
as I'm looking at all this stuff,
trying to understand the currents of
what's going on,
I'd find I'd have to go read like the
most crazy leftist stuff and then I'd
have to go find some gnarly alt-right
garbage and have to go there and read
all these preposterous arguments,
racist,
shitty arguments on both sides.
Just ridiculous stuff to them because
even amongst some crazy racist or some,
some crazy,
you know,
communist,
either way,
there's got to be some truth there that
they figure is useful to their argument
that may be different from the other,
but it still doesn't change it from
being true.
It's like,
uh,
you can't,
the truth doesn't change from place to
place.
You,
you can't,
you can't change it anymore and you can
salt salt,
uh,
said by Cormac Mccarthy and it's like,
well I have to now go outside of this
because I can't find anyone new sources
going to be completely honest with me.
So then I have to look and all these
places and then try to piece this whole
story together based on what truth I can
find.
And honestly it,
it got to be so tiring and reading just
crazy shit on each side and having to,
it's just like,
well,
some of this stuff,
it's just so fucking fucked up and it's
not like I needed a trigger warning or
something like that,
but it's just,
he's just gets tiring it.
They didn't also think like people
coming up with like,
uh,
racial Iq things,
trying to create some,
some idea there and I'm like,
ah,
fuck man,
this is,
people believe this.
It's like trying to to navigate flat
earth shit and stuff like that and go,
come on.
I hear it.
The first time I read it,
I'm like,
okay,
yeah,
whatever.
You just don't get it.
But then when I see that there's even
some small amount of traction,
it's just fucking disappointing.
It's very disappointing.
Yeah.
Well,
it's too easy to get by today and
there's a lot of dummies that have
gotten bots,
right.
That's one of my arguments is that this
is the softest,
easiest fucking way of living we've ever
had.
Now I understand there are difficulties,
but are difficult.
Even our poor are still more wealthy
than like the 90% of the world or
something like that.
It's true.
Crazy.
Yeah.
If you make more than $34,000 a year,
you were in the top 1% of the world.
Yeah.
And we don't,
we don't see it that way.
No.
You know,
we're too busy thinking about what we
don't have or what we should have or
what,
how are we deserve more than this person
or that person or how you know,
you know,
if you want to argue about the
difficulty it is to buy a home nowadays,
I'm totally willing to listen.
If you want to argue about the,
the shady aspects of banks,
I'm there with you.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
But if you just want to start trying to
cut me down into some specific class and
minimal to minimize me and then devalue
my opinion or who I am,
it's just like I'm not going to,
I understand the,
the biological potential for tribalism
and the fear of the thing of it is the
unknown being maybe too much of a risk.
So if you look at wild animals,
they don't really get into fights all
that much.
If they can help it,
because the risk of being injured,
maimed,
or dead,
potentially,
it's just too much.
She had,
most of the time they get into their
little scraps and they disperse,
right?
And if you're a full on Alpha,
you normally don't get into any fucking
fights whatsoever.
It's the bait is always trying to like
pick their way up and maybe eventually
find an Alpha that's that they might
perceive having a weakness.
But once they finally get to that point
that they're going to really fucking
full on fight,
it means everything because everything
is at risk.
Well,
you know,
you look at some cave people,
it was probably the same way the first
time.
You know,
uh,
one group sees someone that looks
completely different from them.
They're like,
oh,
what the fuck is that?
Can I risk it?
Is it going to destroy my community?
Is it going to be damaging to,
you know,
it's like cave man shit because they
don't understand until somebody creates
an understanding.
So,
uh,
but it's very hard for people to accept
other people's ideas.
Of course your ideas are different and
then their ideas,
you want their ideas to align with
yours.
And in the case where we're talking
about with a lot of these people,
they're trying to enforce or ideas on
other people,
you will now obey and go along with my
standards of behavior and thought it's
insecurity and it's fear.
And,
but to me I'm like,
okay,
I can understand that on that base
element,
but we have the ability to overcome
that,
to be greater than that,
to be better than that,
to not to not sit there and,
and value people on all these surface
level shit.
You know?
I mean you can,
you could stereotype things all you want
and be like,
oh well this looks like a duck and
quacks like a duck and this looks like
it.
Goosing Hong,
like whatever.
Fine.
But if you try to continue to keep
people in these places,
you're,
you're diminishing who they are.
You're also,
you're creating this,
this element of prejudice.
You're creating those barriers for,
for that to,
not for that interaction to not happen.
You're the one that's,
that's helping create that,
that tribalistic element.
And so as you continue to widdle these
people down in a more and more groups,
but you know,
with the,
that now when you couch that in with
this neo Marxist elements,
it's like,
well,
now you need the more tiny or the group
you get,
the more you get to be oppressed,
the more you're a victim of something.
And so,
yeah,
them,
it's a good market share and being a
victim,
we've got to get out of your mouth.
I gotta end this Josh Barnett.
So what's the future right now?
No fights.
Scheduled,
no fights.
I am,
you know,
uh,
actually I'm still dealing with my Usada
stuff.
Uh,
we have to,
my understanding,
but my management saying is that you
sought out to a completely satisfied
with understanding that,
uh,
that this supplement that I took was
tainted.
And then we even went out and after they
tested the one that I gave them,
they went out and bought a whole brand
new bottle on,
opened,
tested that one again laced with the
same shit.
And they had already,
you know,
they had tested me not even that,
that much in between are they testing me
in between like or there was barely any
time in between test anyways.
So my managers telling me that the guy
at the lab is going,
well this is such a negligible amount
that it looks like you've been whatever
you took was tainted in the first place.
So because there's no reason why a guy
your size would even bother to have such
a negligible amount of whatever this
shit is and your system.
And I'm like especially since two to
explain that between the last test and
this test,
yes you would have,
it would be such a small amount,
right,
that there's no way that you were on
something and you cycled off.
Exactly.
It didn't make any sense.
They have you suspended too.
I don't know.
The thing is,
is that we've gone through,
I've spent like two grand having
supplements tested cause I would keep
bits of everything that I would take
just in case and keep him around.
And uh,
Christ,
you know,
and I,
this was a brand I'd taken before.
This was a,
a supplement that had been an ingredient
and other stuff that I've never had a
problem with.
You know,
I always would check everything against
that global drove thing.
I would do all their steps about cross
referenced this,
that and the other always.
Okay.
You know,
making sure that I'm always on a towing
the,
are not toeing the line,
but uh,
being up front on this and doing what
they said too.
And then,
you know,
all right,
so I got some,
some bullshit and something I didn't
expect.
So,
all right,
we go,
we test it.
They go in a,
they,
they back their findings up with a
completely brand new bottle and batch
that matches the one that,
I haven't acted on that and now I'm
still waiting,
but I,
I'm
still suspended,
but I don't,
I don't understand.
You know what,
what,
what more could I do?
Right.
You know what I mean?
All right dude.
Um,
Josh l Barnett on twitter and instagram.
Instagram.
Yeah.
Thanks brother.
Those was just fun.
Always in here.
You're going to do another podcast.
You're going to start at the war machine
chronicles war machines soon.
I mean war machine.
I say,
that doesn't mean that when you more
Master Sis Warren m,
they just flow together so well fucked
up the end of the podcast.
Ladies and gentlemen helped me want to
change major bummer war master.
We give out a couple other nicknames,
haven't you?
Baby face assassin.
What was the other one?
Philadelphia.
Jailbird.
Josh Barnett.
Ladies Gentlemen.